ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is
Dr. Kyle Gillett.
Dr. Kyle Gillett is a dual
board certified physician
in family medicine and
obesity medicine and an expert
in hormone optimization.
He is an M.D--
that is, a medical doctor--
and he treats patients
with a variety
of backgrounds, ages and goals.
Today, we discuss male
hormone optimization.
We discuss behavioral tools,
nutrition-based tools,
supplement-based tools,
prescription-drug-based tools,
and their interactions in
determining overall levels
of testosterone,
free testosterone,
dihydrotestosterone, estrogen,
growth hormone, thyroid
hormone, and many other
hormones that impact mood,
libido, well-being,
strength, cognition,
and various
psychological factors.
We've covered
hormone optimization
in both men and women
in previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
but today's discussion
is different.
Dr. Kyle Gillett offers very
specific recommendations
for people with different
goals and of different ages.
And we get deep
into the weeds of,
for instance, how does
one know whether or not
their testosterone is optimized
or not, how often to test
for specific hormones
such as testosterone
and other hormones, and
really, how to gauge
how good one should feel?
This is something that's often
overlooked in discussions
about hormone optimization
or health optimization
of any kind, for that matter.
For instance, people will
talk about reduced libido
and discuss whether or not
testosterone levels are
to blame, but how does
one calibrate their libido
in the first place?
That is, how does one know
whether or not their libido is
normal, too low, or too high?
We also discuss, for
instance, whether or not
hormone optimization should
be pursued continually
throughout the
year-- for instance,
whether or not you should
cycle on and off supplements
and/or prescription drugs geared
towards hormone optimization.
And we discuss the
behavioral foundations
of optimal hormone function.
These are things that
every male should be doing
and various things
they should actively
avoid if their goal is to
have healthy hormones and to,
quote, unquote, optimize
their levels of every hormone
from growth hormone
to testosterone
at any stage of life.
And while today's discussion
is about male hormone
optimization, I
want to emphasize
that we discuss all the
various ages for male hormone
optimization.
So for those of you that are
parents, for those of you that
are young, those of you that
are middle aged, or old,
or teenagers, we explore
adolescent, puberty,
teen and late teens, early
adulthood, adulthood,
and into the late
geriatric ages.
So regardless of
your age and whether
or not you are male or
female, today's episode
ought to be of interest to you.
I should also point out
that we will soon also
be hosting an expert guest on
female hormone optimization.
One thing that I'm
certain people of all ages
and biological sex will enjoy
about today's conversation
is that we also get
into descriptions
of how psychology and life
events impact hormones
and how hormones impact
our psychology and the way
that we show up to
various life events.
So today is really
a broad overview
that goes all the way down to
fine details about male hormone
optimization.
And I'm certain that by
the end of today's episode,
you will have an immense amount
of new information about how
this endocrine-- that is,
hormone system in your body
works--
and how it interacts with
your brain and other tissues
and many, many actionable tools
that you can pursue regardless
of stage of life.
Before we begin, I'd
like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to
consumer information
about science and
science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with
that theme, I'd like
to thank the sponsors
of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics.
And as I've said many times
before on this podcast,
I am not a fan of
the word nootropics,
because it means smart
drugs, and frankly, there
are no specific neural circuits
in the brain or body for being,
quote, unquote, smart.
Thesis understands
this, and they've
developed custom nootropics
that are designed
to bring your brain and
body into the state that's
ideal for what you
need to accomplish.
They use the highest
quality ingredients-- things
like phosphatidylserine,
alpha GPC, many ingredients
that I've talked about
before on this podcast
and that I happen to use myself.
I've been using Thesis
for over a year now,
and I can confidently say
that their nootropics have
been a game changer.
For me, I like their
nootropic for clarity.
I used that before
cognitive work often.
And I like their
nootropic for energy,
and I often used
that before workouts,
and in particular, workouts
that are especially intense.
To get your own personalized
nootropic starter kit,
go online to
takethesis.com/huberman,
take their 3-minute quiz,
and Thesis will send you four
different formulas to
try in your first month.
Again, that's
takethesis.com/huberman,
and use the code Huberman
at checkout to get 10% off
your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA.
ROKA makes eyeglasses
and sunglasses
that are of the absolute
highest quality.
The company was founded
by 2 All-American swimmers
from Stanford, and everything
about ROKA eyeglasses
and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind.
I've spent a lifetime
working on the biology
of the visual system,
and I can tell you
that your visual
system has to contend
with an enormous number
of challenges in order
for you to see clearly,
for instance, when you move
from a sunny area
to a shady area
and back again, whether or not
you're looking at something up
close or off into the distance.
ROKA understands the biology
of the visual system,
and has designed their
eyeglasses and sunglasses
accordingly so that you always
see with perfect clarity.
ROKA eyeglasses and
sunglasses were initially
designed for activities
such as running and cycling,
and indeed, they are
very lightweight.
Most of the time, I
can't even remember
that they're on my face
they're so lightweight.
But the important thing to
know about ROKA eyeglasses
and sunglasses is
that while they
can be used during
sports activities,
they also have a
terrific aesthetic
and they can be
used just as well
for wearing to work, or
out to dinner, et cetera.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses,
you can go to roka--
that's R-O-K-A--
.com and enter the code Huberman
to save 20% off on your first
order.
Again, that's roka-- R-O-K-A--
.com and enter the code
Huberman at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Helix Sleep.
Helix makes
mattresses and pillows
that are of the absolute
highest quality.
I started sleeping on a Helix
mattress well over a year ago,
and it's been the best
sleep that I've ever had.
One of the things that makes
Helix mattresses so unique
is that they match the
design of the mattress
to your unique sleep needs.
So for instance, if you
go on to their website.
You can take a brief quiz.
It only takes about
two or three minutes,
and you'll answer
questions like do
you tend to run hot or
cold throughout the night,
or whether or not you sleep
on your back, your side,
or your stomach, or
maybe you don't know.
Regardless, they will match
you to the custom mattress
that ideal for your sleep needs.
For me, that was the dusk--
D-U-S-K-- mattress which,
for me, was not too firm,
not too soft, and was ideal
for my sleep patterns.
You take the quiz
and you'll find out
what mattress is ideal
for your sleep patterns.
So if you're interested in
upgrading your mattress,
go to helixsleep.com/huberman,
take their brief sleep quiz,
and they'll match you to
a customized mattress,
and you'll get up to $200 off
any mattress order and two free
pillows.
They have a 10 year
warranty, and you
get to try out the mattress
for 100 nights risk-free.
Again, if you're
interested, you can go
to helixsleep.com/huberman for
up to $200 off and two free
pillows.
The Huberman Lab
podcast is now partnered
with Momentous Supplements.
To find the supplements we
discuss on the Huberman Lab
podcast, you can go to
livemomentous-- spelled O-U-S--
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And I should just
mention that the library
of those supplements is
constantly expanding.
Again, that's
livemomentous.com/huberman.
And now, for my discussion
with Dr. Kyle Gillett.
Dr. Gillett, great
to have you back.
KYLE GILLETT: Great to be back.
Thank you.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd like to
begin with a question about one
of the most mysterious and
important phases of life, which
is puberty.
I've long wondered whether or
not how quickly somebody goes
into puberty-- so at what age--
and how long puberty
takes-- so how
brief or protracted
that puberty is
for them to acquire the
so-called secondary sexual
characteristics,
things like hair growth
on the face for males and
changes in bone, and muscle
density, and growth, et cetera.
When I was in middle
school and high school,
I noticed that some people
transitioned into all that
very fast and some people
took a long time to acquire
those characteristics.
Can we learn anything about
ourselves, our hormones,
and maybe even how
long we're going
to live based on the time
in which we enter puberty
and how long it takes us to
progress through puberty?
And I guess that also
raises the question,
does puberty ever truly end?
KYLE GILLETT: There are
many takeaways from puberty.
Some of the actionable items
from it are, yes, it can
and does affect your adult
height and also stature
and also body composition.
So puberty is a time--
and if we're talking
specifically about males,
think of it as a time where,
if you have obesity as a child,
you could potentially
use that time
to change your lifestyle
and habits and reset things,
and it is a bit easier.
It's almost like
a free injection
of testosterone and metabolism
and drive and effort
into your life.
There is a wide variation in how
quickly puberty goes through.
So there are stages called
Tanner stages, which we don't
necessarily need to get into.
But if you enter
puberty very early,
then it can decrease your
adult height or stature.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So for a
given male that enters puberty
at 13 versus a male that
enters puberty at 15,
can we say that the guy
that entered puberty at 13
is going to be shorter than the
guy that entered puberty at 15,
or it's not quite
that straightforward?
KYLE GILLETT: If they
are identical twins
and the individual
who entered puberty
at age 13 also finished
puberty, went all the way
through the Tanner stages--
and if you do a bone
scan, which I believe
is usually done
on the left wrist,
and it says yes, your growth
plates are mostly closed,
you're not going to grow more
than a couple inches of height
after that.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Just
a related question.
When I was growing
up, it was thought,
or at least people would say,
that resistance training--
in particular,
lifting heavy weights
could stunt one's growth.
Is that true or false?
KYLE GILLETT: It is
false when you're
talking about just
lifting heavy weights.
Dirty bulking certainly
has the potential to stunt
one's growth for
two main mechanisms.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Could
you define dirty bulking?
KYLE GILLETT: [CHUCKLES]
So dirty bulking
is eating an excess of
calories not just to acquire
lean metabolically active
body mass or get stronger,
but purposely
acquiring body fat.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
purposely acquiring muscle
and fat by overeating
and lifting weights
can stunt one's growth.
Do I have that correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
So it does two things.
If you're doing it as a
very young child, it can--
that fat can become
leptin resistant
and it can produce more
leptin, and that leptin
can activate the
hypothalamus, which
activates the pituitary, which
releases gonadotropin, which
basically just
increase testosterone
and estrogen earlier than
it otherwise would have.
It's the same mechanism behind
why childhood obesity causes
early puberty.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
I do remember a paper
published in Science Magazine--
I believe it was focused
mainly on females,
but showing that when
enough body fat accumulates,
the hormone leptin
is secreted, and that
triggers the onset of puberty.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Given the
increase in childhood obesity
that we're observing
now, are we seeing
an earlier onset of puberty
in males and females?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes, in
both males and females.
Not to get too
technical, but there's
a G protein-coupled
receptor on the hypothalamus
and leptin directly
binds it, so it
does appear directly
cause causatory and not
just correlation.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And if
I understand correctly,
what you're saying is
for a young guy-- let's
say, 13, 14-- who
wants to really bulk up
and deliberately-- deliberately,
excuse me-- overeats, and is
doing their squats, and
deadlifts, and bench presses
and really trying to get big,
they will get big, but only
in the lateral dimension.
They're effectively
limiting their total height
and it can shut down the long
bone growth of their limbs.
Is that correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
The growth of the long
bones is mostly related
to the estradiol alpha
receptor, so basically,
one of the receptors
for estrogen,
which can be secondary
to early puberty and also
is related to body fat because
you have that conversion
of testosterone to estrogen.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So can we
assume that if a young male
wants to get into resistance
training that bodyweight
exercises are probably OK
and maybe even some weight
training, kettlebells,
et cetera,
but that they should avoid
doing so-called dirty bulking--
trying to deliberately
gain weight--
up until what age?
Until puberty is over?
KYLE GILLETT: I would say
an individual should limit
the amount of abnormal
body fat accumulation,
or dirty bulking, indefinitely
throughout their entire life.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So again,
if I understand correctly,
that recommendation to
avoid deliberate weight gain
or rapid weight gain is not
just to allow an individual
to reach their maximum height,
but also to avoid laying down
a lot of body fat cells.
Correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
The balance between
that is, when
you are going
through puberty, you
are able to add a lot
of lean body mass--
not just muscle mass, but bone
mass and other mass as well.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I started
lifting weights when I was 16,
and I confess I trained
pretty heavy at times.
I don't know whether
or not I would
have been taller than
I am now, but when
I started that
training, I had already
reached what was at least
close to my predicted height.
I can't say that I deliberately
waited until I had grown.
It just so happened that I
stumbled into the weight room
and found that I liked it
at age 16, at which point,
I was already the
height that I am now.
So in any case,
what I'm hearing is
that laying down a lot of excess
body fat is not a good idea.
What if somebody grows up chubby
or fat for whatever reason--
reasons related to the eating
patterns in their family,
maybe even some genetic reasons.
Is it safe and/or wise
for a young person--
so let's say somebody who's
around the age of puberty,
or even younger, or in their
late teens-- to be dieting
and actively trying
to lose body fat.
Is that safe?
KYLE GILLETT: Under the
supervision of a physician,
it is certainly safe to
change your body composition.
In pediatric obesity
medicine, you're
often talking about
a recomposition
or a renormalization of the
growth curve compared to peers.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Great.
Thank you.
So as you may have sensed,
we started chronologically
with puberty, and
I know that there's
another puberty that even
precedes the puberty that we're
all familiar with.
Maybe-- if you want to
just briefly mention
that because I was talking
with you about this
before we started.
The puberty that I'm
most familiar with,
and I think most people
are most familiar with,
the acquisition of
deepening of the voice,
growth of muscle and bone, body
hair, acquisition of libido
and things like that.
That's actually the second
puberty that we all go through.
Maybe would just mention
for us and educate us
on the first puberty.
I think most people
will be hearing
this for the very first time.
KYLE GILLETT: The first
puberty of everyone's life
is the first three
months of their life.
You may notice that your baby
has more acne the first three
months and that they also have,
in general, just more changes
related to androgens and
estrogens, perhaps oilier skin,
even more genitourinary--
genital growth during
the first three months.
And this is mostly due to DHEA,
which is an adrenal hormone.
The second puberty,
or the puberty
that most people know of,
actually starts that same way
as well.
It's called adrenarche, and
it's when the adrenals kick in,
I guess, for the second time.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Is there
a standard age or age
range in which the
testicles descend in males?
KYLE GILLETT:
Usually before birth.
It is not uncommon to have one
or even two undescended testes,
but there is a risk
of testicular cancer,
especially if they are
not fixed early and also
heat damage to the teste.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well,
thank you for that coverage
of the two puberties.
So early in life.
I imagine some of our
listeners probably
still in one or the-- well,
one or the other puberty.
The ones that are in
the first puberty,
obviously, aren't
aware that they're
listening to this
podcast, but maybe it'll
be embedded in
their subconscious.
But some listeners probably
are still in puberty.
But I think everyone can
remember back to their puberty,
and roughly when they
first entered puberty,
and how quickly they
aggregated the secondary sex
characteristics.
I'd like to turn now to a
general question about what
all males ought to do in order
to optimize their hormones.
So if you could just
list off the things
that all males should do on
a daily basis, weekly basis.
I mean, should guys
in their teens and 20s
be getting their bloodwork
done, should they
be taking supplements?
We already talked
about weight training.
What should they be doing
and what should they
avoid doing if the
goal is to have
a long arc of healthy
hormone optimization
throughout the lifespan?
KYLE GILLETT: There's many
things that you should do.
An analogy that I
often make is when
there's a brand new car that
comes off the assembly line,
you do a full scope
of diagnostic workup--
hook it up to the computer.
And I think we should do the
same thing with humans as well.
During puberty, obviously,
you're a functioning human,
but I would say there's
still development.
And I think that the
human always develops.
I don't think
development ever ends,
but you want to
monitor that progress
across a person's lifespan.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh, sorry.
So for bloodwork-- I mean,
what would be the earliest--
let me put it this way.
If blood work didn't cost
anything and everyone
could get it, when
would you want
to see everybody get
their bloodwork done
for the first time?
Obviously, individuals
under the age of 18
should talk with their
parents about this.
And as long as the
parents and the child
agree and the parents are
on board with this as well,
you can start getting bloodwork.
Often, a child will
come in with complaints
of either precocious
puberty or delayed puberty,
and this individual might be 9
or this individual might be 15.
For a healthy
child, when they're
going through their later
Tanner stages-- which
is 4 and 5, so they've developed
several secondary sexual
characteristics-- they might
have hair growth or starting
to notice more beard growth.
That's a good time to do it.
If you're concerned
with stature or heighth,
or if you're not
tracking along where most
members of your family have--
not just their height
and stature, but also
the timing of their puberty,
then that's time to get labs.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So if I
could travel back in time,
I would have gotten my bloodwork
done for hormones, and lipids,
and everything else at 18.
I, unfortunately, didn't know
where and how to get that,
and I didn't have any
pressing clinical issues.
And so I think the first time
that I got my bloodwork done,
I was in my late 20s,
maybe even in my early 30s.
And I'm still dying to
know what my bloodwork was
when, for instance, I was
17 and I felt a certain way.
And I confess that
in many dimensions,
I actually feel better now at--
I'll be 47 soon-- at 47 than
I did in my teens and 20s.
And I think it was more
on the psychological side.
I think that-- but in
terms of just understanding
why we felt great or why we
felt or feel terrible or not so
great, I think bloodwork
is extremely informative.
What do you think
are the key things
to look for in bloodwork?
I mean, testosterone is
always the topic that comes up
in the context of male
hormone optimisation,
but certainly there are
a lot of other hormones
that are important as well.
KYLE GILLETT: And
with testosterone, you
want to get either
testosterone and an SHBG
or a free testosterone.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Could you
define SHBG for our listeners,
please?
KYLE GILLETT: It is Sex
Hormone Binding Globulin.
It is the protein that
binds up all androgens
and estrogen in the body.
So the stronger the androgen,
the stronger it binds.
During puberty,
strong androgens,
especially DHT which
is the strongest
bioidentical androgen,
has a huge role--
a prominent role in secondary
sexual characteristics.
And if your SHBG is
very high, then your DHT
can run higher because
it's not metabolized,
but there's not quite
as much free DHT.
So you want to balance
between a high enough free DHT
and a high enough total DHT.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
obviously, these blood tests
are going to have to
be read and interpreted
by a qualified physician.
Most people aren't going to be
in a position to evaluate them
properly, or at least not with
the full depth that they could
if they had an M.D like
yourself looking at them.
So everyone should get
bloodwork as early as possible
depending on their
budget and availability.
What should
everybody do in terms
of monitoring those markers?
So assuming that there's
no major intervention,
how often do you
recommend that people
get their bloodwork done?
KYLE GILLETT: Let's say--
let's take an individual
who just turned 18,
they just got their
first set of bloodwork.
They'll probably
find something in it
that they may want to optimize
using shared decision-making
with their physician.
Usually, a good follow-up
is about six months.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So twice a
year, getting bloodwork done,
and then having a
physician evaluate it.
That sounds reasonable to me.
And for those that didn't
initiate this at 18,
such as myself, I guess
the best time to start then
would be as soon as possible.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: In
terms of the other things
that all males should do,
meaning all males of all ages--
puberty and beyond-- what
are some of those things?
So on a daily basis,
maybe you could just
take us through the arc
of a day and push out
some of the protocols
that you use
or the things that you like
to see your male patients
use in order to try and
optimize their hormone status.
KYLE GILLETT: I'll briefly
touch on some of the lifestyle
pillars to start.
Diet and exercise
are the first to.
In puberty, sleep is
particularly important,
of course.
But with diet and exercise,
throughout a lifespan,
you want to not exclude
things that are helping you.
For example, during
puberty if you're
consuming dairy, and then all of
a sudden you cut out all dairy,
dairy can help increase
IGF-1 and free IGF-1.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And just,
again, for our audience,
maybe just mention what
having enough IGF-1 can
do for us that's beneficial is?
KYLE GILLETT: It helps you grow.
It helps with
genital development,
secondary sexual
characteristics, and long bone
growth--
skin growth, hair
growth, a host of things.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So getting
an array of nutrients
that include dairy.
What other sorts
of nutrients are
important during development?
KYLE GILLETT: You want to have
adequate vitamin D. Vitamin
D helps with
testosterone production,
it helps, again, with bone
mineralization and stature.
After an age of about 25--
and there's not a strict cutoff,
but up to about an age of 25,
optimizing your growth
hormone and IGF-1
helps with bone density
and bone growth.
So from the dietary
standpoint, you
want to have enough free
estrogen-- not too much
when you're growing.
But you want to help
basically stockpile bone
to prevent a risk of
osteoporosis or thin bone
fractures when you're older.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Well, as someone
who broke his left foot 5
times while in high school,
I can say that whatever
young people can
do to optimize their bone
density would be great.
That problem seems to have
resolved itself over time,
but I don't know.
Back then, I did a short
run as a vegetarian,
but I've always
been an omnivore.
I realize that some
of this relates
to ethics, and food allergies,
and things of that sort.
But would you say
that, on balance,
most people would benefit from
eating a combination of quality
proteins from animal sources
and non-animal sources--
fruits, vegetables,
and starches?
I mean, what do you
think, for instance,
about people following a pure
carnivore or a very pure vegan
diet in their 20s and 30s?
KYLE GILLETT: In
their late 20s, it
might be a reasonable option.
In early 20s and
certainly teens,
it is a horrible idea because
it is likely to significantly
decrease your free androgens.
So you will have less
testosterone acting
on receptors through the body.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Are there
any other micronutrients
or macronutrients that
people in their 20s and 30s
should emphasize?
KYLE GILLETT: We haven't really
touched on fatty acids or fiber
too much.
Fiber is going to
be paramount in kind
of setting your set
point of your gut
microbiome the
rest of your life.
There is prebiotic
fiber, which you
can think of as fish food
for your good gut microbiome.
Your gut microbiome is kind
of like an aquarium or a fish
tank.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Now,
I'm just thinking
about goldfish swimming around
in that-- the goldfish eating
people.
Don't eat goldfish, people--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --live or dead.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah,
but any fiber or food
that you're putting
in your gut, it's
either going to skew your gut
microbiome toward something
that is more beneficial
or more detrimental.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And would you say
that the prebiotic fiber and
getting essential fatty acids,
that would be important to do
throughout the lifespan or just
for people in their 20s and 30s?
KYLE GILLETT:
Throughout the lifespan,
particularly important in the
teenage, '20s, '30s, because it
helps with brain development.
You're certainly more
of an expert than me
when it comes to
brain development,
but it does continue
to develop, really,
throughout the lifespan, but
certainly through the 20s
and 30s as well.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: What
about taking a multivitamin
while you're growing up?
So many people do that.
Is it necessary, is it useful?
And if it's not necessary,
is it safe to do anyway?
KYLE GILLETT: It's
generally safe to do anyway.
I do not think everybody
needs a multivitamin.
The more exclusionary
your diet is--
for example, if you
have celiac disease
or if you're planning on
fertility soon, then perhaps
it's more reasonable
to take a multivitamin.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: In a
previous discussion of ours,
I asked you about caloric
restriction and testosterone.
And if I recall correctly, the
idea was that if somebody is
overweight-- they have an
excess fat, adipose tissue--
then getting rid of some
of that adipose tissue
through caloric
restriction and exercise,
provided it's done not
too fast in a healthy way,
is going to be beneficial for
testosterone in the long-run.
But that for
individuals who are not
carrying an excess of body
fat, caloric restriction
is actually going to
lower testosterone.
First of all, do I
have that correct?
And second, are there
any addendums to that
you'd like to give us now?
KYLE GILLETT: That's correct.
If you look at an individual
in a caloric deficit,
several changes will happen.
One is that they'll have less
building blocks for hormones.
Another is that they will
be in a catabolic state
more often, so that balance
of anabolism and catabolism
will be different.
They'll likely have less
signaling from growth hormone
and IGF-1, and they'll
also have the high SHBG
that we defined earlier
as the binding protein,
so their free androgens and
free estrogens will go down.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Got it.
So we touched on
sleep being critical.
I would say throughout
the lifespan, trying
to get enough quality
sleep at least 80%
of the nights of your
life, and the other 20%
are just what happens
when there's noise outside
or you're stressed.
It just-- you have
an exam or you're
having a great time
for whatever reason.
There are a lot of good
reasons to lose some sleep
now and again as well.
So we have sleep,
we've got nutrition.
We touched on that.
We'll get back into
supplementation.
Now, what are some
of the other pillars
of creating the proper
environment for hormone
optimization?
KYLE GILLETT: Stress is
probably the next one.
During both puberty, but
also the 20s and 30s,
individuals are figuring out how
they want to cope with stress
and also figuring out
what they want to choose
to put their effort into.
So if someone is overstressed,
then it can have--
it can put all the other
lifestyle pillars--
and then they stop dieting
well, they stop exercising,
and everything
else can go askew.
There is also some degree
of social component to this,
so perhaps I need to add a
seventh pillar of social.
During your 20s and 30s, you
may be forming a family as well.
Perhaps you have children, and
the health of the family unit
is going to be vitally
important not only-- not
necessarily directly for
hormone optimisation,
but it's going to
throw everything
else off if it's off.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
for people that are not
starting their own families
in their 20s and 30s,
can that social connection
be extended to friendships
and work relationships as well?
KYLE GILLETT: Absolutely.
In fact, if someone's
not starting a family,
it is just as concerning,
but for other reasons.
Each individual is going to
have their close group of family
and friends.
And if someone does not have
one of those connections,
that's when things
can potentially
get bad not just for them
individually, but also society.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
when you say stress,
you mean learn to
manage your stress.
What does that look like?
I mean, if a patient
has high blood pressure,
or even if they don't, you just
sense that they're stressed.
They have a lot of
pressured speech,
or they're not feeling
well, or communicating
that they're not doing well.
What are some of
the things that you
recommend in order to try
and ameliorate that stress?
KYLE GILLETT: There's different
mindfulness or relaxation
techniques.
Going outside can often
help with this as well.
Dietary changes and exercise
can help with this too.
Some people like
prayer or meditation.
And a lot of people like
counseling or therapy,
or even just talking openly with
a family member or a friend.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
What would it be
some of the other pillars
for hormone optimization?
Here, I feel like we're not
just talking about people
in their 20s and
30s, but again, we're
wrapping our arms around
basically puberty onward.
I mean, gosh, looking
back, I started
meditating pretty early,
I started weight training
and running early.
I gave some thought to
my diet in high school,
but it really was
in college that I
started thinking more about
what I was ingesting and why
and trying to do better there.
But people are
coming to the table
at different stages
of life and trying
to optimize for hormones.
So what would be some
of the additional things
that everybody should do?
KYLE GILLETT: Everyone should
get outside and find a movement
pastime to last a lifetime.
You're going to get
sunlight, you're
going to get some degree
of heat and cold exposure,
and you're also just
going to move more.
Being in an artificial
environment, where there's
artificial lights
artificial air conditioning,
is going to have many
effects on your body.
So that's vital.
Another one is finding what
your purpose is in life.
So I call this spirit,
but it's really
just the self-actualization
component of Maslow's hierarchy
of needs, which is basically
your physical needs,
your mental needs, and then
your purpose in life-- what
you really like to do.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
picking some goal or target.
And I always say that
you don't have to stick
to the same goal over time.
Certainly, I haven't
although I got
started early in the science
game and I'm still in it.
The idea is not to pick the
end goal, it is to pick a goal.
And then once you reach that
goal to assess, and then
pick another goal, and so on.
I think sometimes, when people
hear about picking a purpose,
they're like, oh, my
goodness, I have to define--
sort of like naming oneself--
that you actually can change
your goals and purpose
over time.
This is terrific.
Would you suggest that
people actively use
or avoid supplementation
prior to doing
all these other things?
I'm somebody that likes to throw
the kitchen sink at things,
but I also like to do things
pretty systematically.
So I would say behavior is
first, then nutrition, then
supplementation, and then
maybe if, and only if, there's
a real need--
and of course, working with a
doctor-- prescription drugs.
But there are probably
people in their 20s or 30s--
maybe even in their 50s--
that aren't feeling
great, and they
want to do something in order
to be able to train more
or to feel more confident to
seek out social connection.
They just try and go
about the whole business
from the other side as well.
What are your thoughts on that?
KYLE GILLETT: I see
supplements and medications
as very similar--
one is prescribed
and one is not.
In general, medications
have more side effects
or potentially stronger
therapeutic with more efficacy.
But they are just tools
to reach an end goal.
So depending on the
goal, if there's
an individual that's
an athlete, then
certainly they should
consider supplementation.
Or if someone desires
optimal or a very high level
of cognitive performance,
they should also
consider supplementation.
At the same time,
food is medicine,
and a lot of the benefits
you can get in supplements,
you can get in food as well.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
I guess it depends
on how much time and energy
you're willing to spend
and also finances.
I know that when
I was in college,
I could afford just
a few supplements,
and they were basically whey
protein and some fish oil--
I was fortunate
that I was pointed
in the direction of those
things-- and some creatine.
I couldn't afford much else.
Over time, of course,
I could afford more.
But it really does often
depend on finances.
Before we get into some
specific recommendations
to optimize testosterone,
estrogen, thyroid,
growth hormone, et
cetera, I want to ask you
a question I've been wondering
about for a long time.
So often in the discussion
about male hormone optimization,
people will say, well, if
your libido is suffering,
you might want to be
concerned about testosterone--
or even estrogen because we know
that estrogen can impact libido
as well.
Sometimes, having estrogen too
low is detrimental for libido.
Or that people will say, you're
not recovering from workouts
or you're just you're
feeling kind of depressed.
The problem is,
it's all subjective.
[CHUCKLES] So how does
one know whether or not
their recovery from workouts,
their energy, their confidence,
their libido is within
a healthy range?
I mean, obviously, for
people in a relationship
they can know whether or
not their libido matches
the sort of cadence of the
relationship and their partner.
But how should people
think about this
and maybe then start
to talk about it?
Because one of the big
differences, I think,
between males and females
is that, because females
have a monthly cycle, they are
familiar with the changes that
occur in their hormones over
time because every 28 days,
those hormones are
changing dramatically
in ways that impact their
physiology and psychology.
But for males, I
feel like there's
a dearth of language to get
into the more subtle aspects
of this.
It also has to do with
privacy issues and people
feeling like they don't
want to overshare too much--
not knowing what's
appropriate to share.
But when you talk to a
patient who's in their 30s,
or maybe even their
70s or 60s-- it
doesn't matter-- a male patient,
what are you listening for?
And I know you're
not a psychiatrist,
but what are your ears tuned to
in order to try and figure out
whether or not this
person could really
use some help with
hormone optimization
or whether or not
something else--
or maybe they're
just doing great
and they don't realize
it because they're
placing demands on themselves
that are excessive?
KYLE GILLETT: You want to use
a lot of open-ended questions.
This process is called
motivational interviewing.
And your goal is to
listen to the patient
and not plant an
idea in their mind
that they can follow
because everybody is
going to have a different goal.
Some people are better at
reading their biofeedback
or telling how they
feel on a daily basis.
There is screening
questionnaires designed--
for example, an
ADAM questionnaire
to look at men's men's health
and hormone-related health.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
called ADAM questionnaire?
KYLE GILLETT: ADAM
questionnaire.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: A-D-A-M?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Is
it available online
that people could
administer it to themselves.
Although we don't
want people making
clinical diagnoses of
themselves or anyone else,
is it that sort of exam?
KYLE GILLETT: It is.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
KYLE GILLETT: I don't believe it
is a clinically-validated tool
like an ASCVD, which is like a
risk of heart attack and stroke
tool or many other tools.
There's one for depression,
there's one for anxiety.
They're called PHQ9
and GAD7 respectively.
But anyway, there
is often an in--
the ADAM questionnaire-- and
what you hear from the patient,
if you are a very careful
listener, is often different.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Can
you give me an example
of some of the questions
on this ADAM questionnaire
or the sorts of motivational
interviewing that you might do?
So let's say I'm your patient.
I sit down.
What sorts of
questions would you
ask to probe these kinds
of dimensions of hormones?
KYLE GILLETT:
Questions about libido,
questions about
athletic performance,
questions about motivation.
And often, the patient
will answer one thing,
but what you hear from them
subjectively is far different.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
Can you give me an
example of a question?
I'm happy to be the
guinea pig here.
KYLE GILLETT: A classic
one is, a guy comes in--
and a lot of times,
they say, oh, no,
the wife made me
go to the doctor.
I go once a year, that's it.
I don't want anything, I
don't want any medications.
Their screening
questionnaires might be zeros
across the board, so nothing.
No issues.
They're apparently
in perfect health.
They talk to you for a
while, they get some rapport,
they like you, and then right
as you're finishing up the visit
and about to go
out the room, they
mention that their
libido isn't quite there,
and they're having a
little bit of ED as well,
and perhaps they're
even having some chest
pressure or tightness.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I see.
So right as you're
leaving the room,
a patient will tell you that
they're having some sexual side
effects-- or not side effects.
They're having some
sexual challenges,
and then they'll
mention chest pressure.
Is the chest pressure
a general decoy
for, it's got to be
my heart, or is it
related to the other things
that they're reporting?
KYLE GILLETT: It can be related.
In fact, erectile
dysfunction is known
as the canary in the coal mine.
So coal miners would take the
canary down, and it would--
the canary would die before
the coal miners would
of, I believe, carbon
monoxide poisoning.
And often, one of
the causes of ED
is plaque buildup, which
can happen in the coronaries
as well.
But sometimes, they notice
the symptom in the genitals
before they do in
the coronaries.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
for such a patient,
let's say that patient
was a young person where
plaque buildup in the
arteries and veins
is not all that likely
if they're, let's say,
in their 20s or
30s, what would be
your next step of the interview
at that point, and what would
you consider?
Would you immediately
order labs for that person
to try and rule out any
kind of actual hormone level
deficiency?
KYLE GILLETT: I certainly
would order labs.
There are some individuals
that are very similar,
and they come in, and they
have the same symptoms,
and one individual might have
a very, very high testosterone,
and one individual might
be severely hypogonadal.
So there's a big difference
between the subjective
and what the labs look like.
So I certainly order labs.
You also ask them about if
it's situational or not,
you ask them if they
have ED if they're--
you ask them about their habits.
You even ask about
porn, and masturbation,
and all these issues.
And of course, that's between
the doctor and the patient.
And depending on
what they tell you,
you can often determine if there
is a situational component--
some people call
it psychogenic ED,
but I don't love the
term psychogenic ED,
because it kind of puts some
blame on the patient's mind.
But a lot of the time,
that is the case.
There is even a test.
And this is very rarely
ordered, but it's called
a nocturnal penile tumescence.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Now,
is it true that there
are periodic erections
during sleep-- correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
So you basically
put a cuff to see
if you were having a normal
sized erection during sleep.
And I believe about 90% of
the time they do that test,
they are indeed
having erections.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Which would point
to this psychogenic
origin of whatever
challenges they're having in
terms of sexual interactions.
You mentioned porn
and masturbation.
This topic has come up a
bunch of times on this podcast
and on other
podcasts I've gone on
because of the relationship
between dopamine sexual
motivation and sexual behavior.
And I've been of the
pretty strong stance
that, while I'm not judging
porn or masturbation,
it can create a brain
wiring situation where
males in particular
essentially teach their brain
to be aroused by watching other
people have sex as opposed
to being the first person
actor in sexual interactions.
So in that sense, that's
more about the brain wiring,
and neuroplasticity,
and dopamine.
But what are your thoughts
on porn and masturbation
as they relate to hormones?
I mean, this is a big
debate on the internet.
In fact, one of the
most common debates
is whether or not masturbation
increases or decreases
testosterone in males.
Certainly, it will
decrease motivation
to go find sexual partners.
We know this.
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And there
are more and more data on this
all the time.
In terms of the effects of
pornography and masturbation--
and here, I suppose we need
to be somewhat specific
and operationally define
what we're talking about.
We're talking about
porn and masturbation
to the point of ejaculation,
because my understanding
is that the ejaculation
and orgasm associated with
causes an increase in
prolactin, which blunts
libido for some period of time.
The duration of that will
vary from person to person
and circumstance
to circumstance.
But basically, all of
this points to the fact
that porn and
masturbation can really
limit libido in the real world.
And to me, pornography and the
screen is not the real world.
Although screens exist
in the real world,
the real world doesn't
exist in the screen.
KYLE GILLETT: That's
an accurate statement,
and prolactin does have a
significant acute increase
after ejaculation.
It does to some degree
after orgasm as well,
but prolactin acts
on the pituitary
to inhibit the release of
the hormones LH and FSH,
of which LH can
increase testosterone.
So this may be one
of the cases where
the dose makes the poison.
And if it is a very
frequent habit,
certainly daily or
more than once a day
would be very detrimental from
a hormonal component not even
taking into account
the neural wiring.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Listen,
I think it's terrific
that you've actually
defined frequency,
because this is the problem
on the internet or even
in the doctor's office.
You'll see descriptions
about pornography
being dangerous
for certain things
or detrimental to hormones.
People say frequent,
but what's frequent?
So you're saying daily
or multiple times per day
would be potentially
detrimental to the hormone
profile of a male of
essentially any age.
KYLE GILLETT: And that's
just for masturbation.
With pornography--
with porn use as well,
it would likely be worse.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
And why is that?
Just the sort of
dopaminergic drive
of the stimulus-- just the
really intense visual stimulus?
KYLE GILLETT:
Dopamine sensitivity.
I think that using the analogy
of a dopamine wave pool,
it would deepen the
pool, but not increase
your supply of dopamine.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Maybe you could
describe the dopamine wave pool
because I think it's such
a powerful way of thinking
about dopamine and
what dopamine does.
In fact, I've always credited
you when I've done it,
but I've generally stolen your
analogy of the dopamine wave
pool because it's so astute.
KYLE GILLETT: The
dopamine wave pool
describes the natural
variation of ups and downs
in your dopamine
or your motivation.
And in the wave pool, depending
on how high the peak is,
you often have a deeper trough.
So you do not want
to high of a peak.
In addition, if your
peak is very, very high--
for example, when you're using
many substances like cocaine
or like amphetamines,
your dopamine
can go so high that
you lose almost all
the water from the
wave pool, and then
when you crash from that,
not only is the trough low,
you have less dopamine in
the pool to begin with.
The dopamine
receptor is extremely
sensitive, as is the
Gaba receptor, which
is an inhibitory receptor,
whereas dopamine is technically
a stimulant more related to
adrenaline and noradrenaline.
The depth of the pool
can change very quick.
So you want to have that
happy medium where you're
fairly near the top, but
you're not so near the top
that the depth of the
pool is going to go down.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So if I
interpret that in the context
of this discussion about libido,
sex, porn, and masturbation,
if somebody has a very intense
sexual experience-- and here,
we're not necessarily talking
about an intense orgasm--
we're talking about just a lot
of intense visual, so very--
a lot of intense imagery,
or auditory input, or both--
that is going to
lead to a situation
where dopamine is going
to be depleted afterwards.
A guest on this podcast before--
my colleague at Stanford, Dr.
Anna Lembke, who's an
expert in addiction,
talked a bit about this--
the sort of seesawing.
Like, here, we're talking
about a wave and a crashing
out of the water
from the wave pool.
There, it was a seesawing
from pleasure and pain.
There's going to be a longer
and deeper period of lack
of pleasure following that.
And I think a lot of people
think, oh, well, that's great.
They want the
intense experience.
But if that intense experience
is coming from pornography
and masturbation-- or I suppose
coming from high adrenaline
activities, like life-risking
parkour hanging off the side
of a building-- it inevitably
is going to lead to depressive
episodes, low libido
episodes that follow.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct-- in
a similar physiologic way
to withdrawal from
stimulants, like amphetamines.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Now, is sex
with a partner different?
Because there are
many people who
are chasing more
and more intense
experiences with a partner as
opposed to through pornography
and masturbation.
Again, here, we're
talking about all ages.
And I should always say,
anytime we're talking about sex
with a partner, we're talking--
the four conditions that I
always lay out on the Huberman
Lab podcast are that we're
talking about consensual,
age appropriate, context
appropriate, species
appropriate interactions.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah,
and this is also
a case where the dose
makes the poison.
So if there's-- obviously,
meeting all those criteria,
if they have one preference
that, for both of them,
is a positive experience,
then that is likely OK.
You're not going to be
able to maintain dopamine
over a certain threshold
for a long period of time,
so there very well
may be a crash
from that experience as well.
And that crash may be different
in one partner than the other.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
So I'll draw an analogy to food.
It would be like you don't have
to serve the banquet meal seven
nights of the week,
maybe just two.
Is that right?
And there are other
delicious foods out there?
Can--
KYLE GILLETT: Yes--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --we
use that analogy?
KYLE GILLETT: --that
is very reasonable.
I'm not trying to be PG-13.
I'm just trying to parsimony
Occam's razor the ability
to describe a lot of
things in a few words.
I'd like to return to the key
things that people should do--
or I should say, the key
things that men should
do to optimize their hormones.
So we talked about
getting some movement,
getting some sunlight, getting
quality social connection one
way or the other, avoid
excessively frequent
masturbation and
viewing pornography.
And for some people, zero
might be the optimal number.
And I keep coming back to this--
KYLE GILLETT: For most people.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
--for most people.
Interesting.
I feel so fortunate
to have grown
up prior to the availability
of internet pornography.
I've never been a big
consumer of pornography.
It's just not been
my thing, but I
hear so often from males of
all ages about their addiction
to it, their affliction by it.
It's really a serious
issue, and that's
one of the reasons why
I'm grateful that you're
willing to talk about this
and your clinical experience
with these patients.
I'd like to take a quick
break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors,
Athletic Greens.
Athletic Greens,
now called AG1, is
a vitamin-mineral-probiotic
drink
that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs.
I've been taking Athletic
Green since 2012,
so I'm delighted that they're
sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking
Athletic Greens and the reason
I still take athletic Greens
once or usually twice a day
is that it gets
me the probiotics
that I need for gut health.
Our gut is very important.
It's populated by
gut microbiota that
communicate with the brain, the
immune system, and basically
all the biological
systems of our body
to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health.
And those probiotics
in Athletic Greens
are optimal and vital
for microbiotic health.
In addition, Athletic
Greens contains a number
of adaptogens,
vitamins, and minerals
that make sure that all of my
foundational nutritional needs
are met and it tastes great.
If you'd like to
try Athletic Greens,
you can go to
athleticgreens.com/huberman,
and they'll give you five
free travel packs that make it
really easy to mix up
Athletic Greens while
you're on the road, in the
car, on the plane, et cetera.
And they'll give you a year
supply of vitamin D3, K2.
Again, that's
athleticgreens.com/huberman
to get the five free travel
packs and the year supply
of vitamin D3, K2.
In terms of exercise,
here's-- again,
it's a double-edged sword.
On the one hand, it's
great to get exercise,
but I'm familiar with--
if I train an hour a day--
10 minutes of
warm-up in 50 minutes
to an hour of weight
training or 50 minutes
to an hour of
cardio, I feel great,
especially if, once a week,
I take a complete day off.
That's sort of my
general schedule.
I'm also familiar
with when I go out
for runs that are excessively
long-- two hour runs or I spend
90 minutes in the
gym to frequently,
I start to feel like garbage.
Everything suffers.
My sleep starts to suffer.
It doesn't matter
how much I eat--
I don't seem to recover.
I don't feel well.
So I realize that
recovery ability varies
between individuals,
but what do you
think is a healthy, sustainable
exercise regimen that anyone
can follow that will also
support their hormone status?
KYLE GILLETT: For really
vigorous exercise,
around three to
four times a week
is very sustainable over
a long period of time.
On top of that, you could add
in 3 or four more instances
of less vigorous exercise.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
for less vigorous,
would you mean zone two
cardio where you can hold
a conversation, but
beyond which you can't?
And for more vigorous
you're thinking
weight training or high
intensity interval type
training?
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
You can also weight train
and have some benefit even
at a low to moderate intensity.
If you think about
weight training
where you have-- and it's
not necessarily related
to the incidence of DOMS,
which is Delayed Onset Muscle
soreness.
But if you weight
train lazy or easy
from time to time--
obviously, you
want to weight train
very heavy from time
to time as well because of
more lean body mass growth.
But if you weight
train lighter, you're
going to be able to
do it more often,
and it can still help with
the hypertrophy of collagen--
for example, in
tendons and ligaments.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So here, again, I'd
like to perhaps drill into
this notion of intensity
and light weights because
for me, some of the most
brutal workouts
I've ever done were
in what I would consider
a high repetition range--
15 to 50.
Actually, I went up to Oregon
to watch the International Track
and Field Championships.
We went by to Cameron
Haynes's place--
the Cameron Haynes--
and he and his trainer
put us through a
workout that was
25 to 50 repetitions per set,
and it was done in circuit,
and it was brutal.
So it was light--
I mean, those
weights were nothing.
In some cases, it
was body weight.
But the number of
repetitions was brutal.
So when you say
limiting intensity,
are you talking about limiting
the number of sets to failure,
are you talking
about really being
kind of a lazy bear in the gym?
I like to do that every
once-- so a long rest,
that sort of thing.
What are your thoughts
on that as it relates
to hormone optimization?
So I'll just mention-- and
then I'll let you answer--
I feel best overall when I'm
training for 10 minute warm-ups
and about 45 or 50 minutes
of weight training,
where I'm pretty
lazy between sets.
Two to three minute
rests, training somewhere
in the 6 to 10 rep range,
going to failure every once
in a while, but mostly
getting that sort
of last rep before what
I would think is failure.
No forced reps,
that kind of thing.
And then jogging on the
other days, nice and easy.
When I do that, I feel fantastic
in all other dimensions
of life.
When I train more
intensely than that,
even with lightweight, so
faster cadence and lower rest,
I feel like garbage.
I get a headache, I'm kind of
ornery, everything suffers.
So what are your thoughts on
defining a optimal exercise
strategy for hormones.
I've never measured my
hormones in those two
different contexts,
but I have to imagine
that it's cortisol related.
KYLE GILLETT: When they
study the effect of exercise,
specifically vigorous exercise,
one area that's been studied
is vigorous exercise-- episodes
lasting longer than an hour.
And they usually track it by a
rating of perceived exertion,
which isn't perfect, and it's
not extremely actionable,
but it's helpful for
clinical science.
But the takeaway from that
is, basically, do not--
it is not hormonally helpful
to train, especially regularly
train, vigorously for
longer than an hour.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So I'm happy
to hear that because it sounds
like for most people,
that hour of work
is really the threshold.
I think this is important
for people to hear,
especially males
because I think with all
of the incredible examples
out there of people like Cam,
like David Goggins,
people who are training
for very long periods of time--
and leaving aside all issues of
what people are doing in order
to optimize the recovery, I
think an hour a day of exercise
is just a great program
that most anyone can follow.
And beyond an hour, you start
running into challenges.
And the occasional 90-minute
or two hour workout
is no big deal.
But if you start doing that
more than once every two months,
I think you're
headed for trouble.
Have you seen that in
people's blood work
and in their hormones?
Do you ever see
people that are just
badly overtrained because
they're just training
too hard and too often?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
When the blood work
is particularly bad,
they're often in a large
caloric deficit as well.
There's a synergistic effect
between a caloric deficit.
Even if you're maintaining
adequate protein intake,
you might not be maintaining
adequate iron intake
or adequate vitamin D. And
you're also just literally
in a caloric deficit.
Perhaps low carbs as well,
very low free testosterone.
And they're simultaneously doing
a lot of vigorous exercise.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
I often hear, and I'm starting
to wonder whether or not,
some of the quicker-to-results
nutrition tactics--
things like dropping
all carbohydrates,
or the quicker-to-results
exercise habits,
like starting to do six
day a week really intense
workouts-- whether or
not, in the short run,
they work because they cause
the cosmetic changes that people
are seeking, but that
they really undermine
the overall goal, which
is, at least to me,
to have your hormones Maybe.
not optimized to 100%,
but to always be aiming
for 100% and be close to it
at every stage of life.
KYLE GILLETT:
Consistency is key here.
If you are not
consistent, then the law
of diminishing returns
certainly applies.
So 80% or 90% of the benefit
over many, many months
is far better than 100%,
but only half the time.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah.
One thing that I found
to be tremendously useful
is to finish the workout while
I still have energy, to not take
myself to exhaustion.
And then I'm able to talk
about the dopamine wave pool.
I'm able to sort of
ride that into the rest
of the day feeling great.
I sort of save or bank some
of the vigor from the training
to bring it into my work.
But then again,
I'm not an athlete.
I get paid to think and to
speak, not to lift weights
or to run.
KYLE GILLETT: Another
component of that
is the balance between
your sympathetic,
which is your fight or
flight nervous system,
and your parasympathetic,
which is your rest or digest
nervous system.
There is an anecdote,
which is likely true,
that many elite
bodybuilders are very
parasympathetic besides while
they're lifting weights.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You
mean they're lazy
and they like to eat a lot.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: The lazy bear
in the gym kind of phenomenon.
KYLE GILLETT: Absolutely.
But that being said, after a
very, very vigorous workout--
for example, one where
you're trained to failure,
which bodybuilders and power
lifters do all the time--
you feel the tiredness--
or you feel the strain
from that heavy
sympathetic activity
when you are lifting
a heavy weight,
and it can
potentially affect how
you feel the rest of the day.
So many people who have a job
where that is highly cognitive
do not like to have an
extremely vigorous workout
in the morning, which
is when a lot of people
are able to exercise.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: When I exercise
early in the morning-- that is,
before 9:00 AM--
I have more energy all day long.
If I do it mid-morning,
I have experienced
more of an afternoon crash.
There's probably some
circadian biology in there.
I also noticed-- and I've
actually seen in my bloodwork--
that if I don't get
out for a 45-minute jog
at least once a week,
all of my blood profiles
suffer in a direction that
I don't want them to go.
In particular, testosterone
and estrogen move in directions
that are not
conducive to my goals.
I'd like to talk about
some of the approaches
that people can use in
order to optimize hormones.
And these days, for
better or for worse--
I think for worse--
younger guys are
asking about and using
testosterone replacement
therapy-- so-called TRT.
And I just want to
frame this up by saying
there is no strict
cutoff for what is TRT.
There are plenty of people whose
blood levels of testosterone
and estrogen are within
the normal reference range
and decide to start
doing these things.
Of course, they can
limit fertility.
There are a bunch of
issues even at non, quote,
unquote, steroidal
performance enhancing dosages.
I'd love to frame this up
by first defining our terms,
because one of the
challenges on the internet
is people talk about
TRT, then they'll
talk about performance
enhancing drugs,
they'll talk about steroids.
They're all steroids.
I mean, testosterone, estrogen
are both steroid hormones.
But what one considers
replacement therapy
versus what one considers
performance enhancing
is going to depend.
So here's my question.
Why in the world--
[EMPHASIS] why in the world--
would any male in his teens
or twenties, or even 30s,
whose blood levels of
testosterone and estrogen
are at the appropriate
levels, meaning
within the normal
reference range,
take exogenous testosterone
given all the negative effects
on fertility, some of
the challenges that it
can present if the dosages
aren't quite right, et cetera.
Why would they do
that, certainly
if they are not being paid
for a particular endeavor,
like they're not making money?
If they are playing
a sport, chances
are they're not allowed
to do that anyway.
It's on the banned
substances list.
So to me, it just seems
like a crazy idea.
But then again,
I'm of a generation
that really hasn't thought about
doing that stuff until people
were in their 40s and
50s or even never.
So is there ever a case for
somebody in their 20s or 30s
to take testosterone if
their blood levels are
within the 300 to 900 nanograms
per deciliter reference range?
KYLE GILLETT: Not many cases.
The reason for any performance
enhancing drug, whether or not
it is a steroid, synthetic,
bioidentical, or otherwise,
varies a lot.
Some individuals do it
only for cosmetic reasons
even if it can have
deleterious effects
on the cosmetic
appearance, for example,
of your skin in the long run.
But everyone has their
different reasons.
As far as like when
does the benefit
outweigh the detriment, not
very often if you're in your 20s
and certainly--
probably-- almost hardly never.
There's always rare cases, like
Coleman syndrome and whatnot,
but almost never if
you're very young.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So for people
in their 20s, 30s, and beyond--
40s, et cetera-- whose
testosterone and estrogen
levels are at the
appropriate ratios,
and then within the
normal reference range,
and they feel pretty good--
[CHUCKLES] we talked about
the ADAMs exam-- or this sort
of like feel-pretty-good is code
for libido, energy, recovery,
et cetera, and are
feeling at least
workable for their lifestyle.
For those people,
what can they do
besides get great sleep, train,
but not too hard or too often,
et cetera, et cetera?
What are some of the things in
the realm of supplementation
that can help them optimize
their testosterone and estrogen
without suppressing their
own endogenous production
of testosterone and estrogen?
KYLE GILLETT: Let's mention
creatine is the first one.
Creatine is
interesting because it
has multiple different effects.
It helps with amino
acid synthesis.
It also helps with
oxidative stress.
It can also serve
as the backup fuel
tank for your mitochondria,
so holding backup ATP.
And it does slightly
increase total testosterone,
and it also increases the
conversion of testosterone
to dihydrotestosterone,
so potentially it's
especially useful in men
in even their teenage years
and their 20s.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: You mentioned
the conversion of testosterone
to dihydrotestosterone, and
there is mythology out there
that creatine can
increase hair loss,
I'm guessing because there's
at least one study showing
that creatine can increase DHT--
dihydrotestosterone.
And DHT is one of the
primary hormones that can
promote male pattern baldness.
So the question therefore is,
does creatine supplementation
increase the rate of hair loss?
KYLE GILLETT: Theoretically,
it can, but in each individual,
preventing hair loss
is a very poor reason
to take creatine,
because it's not
going to take you to a
supraphysiologic level,
it's not going to
increase your androgens
to a unnormal level of binding.
So I feel like this--
if that was a reason to not
take creatine for hair loss,
then that's--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
You mean-- sorry--
hair loss is not a reason
to avoid taking creatine?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
Hair loss is not a reason
to avoid taking creatine.
Think of it as just
bringing you to what you
are naturally inclined to have.
If your conversion of
testosterone to DHT
is already high, then often,
creatine does not affect this.
It just kind of
resets your balance
between testosterone being
aromatized to estrogen
or being 5-alpha reduced DHT.
So it's not going to speed
up hair loss more than just
naturally being a male does.
So in some individuals,
it will have no effect.
In some individuals--
for whatever reason,
they have almost no 5-alpha
reductase activity--
it will return them
to natural or normal.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I see.
Well, I take 5 grams a day
of creatine monohydrate.
I do it for the
tissue volumizing
effects, so for
exercise benefits,
but also for the
cognitive effects.
I don't know if it's
increasing my hair loss.
I mean, I've got a little bit
of widow's peak type hair loss.
That's where it is for me.
I suppose beard growth is
associated with DHT too.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
What I learned--
but then again I haven't
been into those literature
in a long time-- is that because
of differences in receptors,
that DHT causes hair
growth on the face and hair
loss on the head.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes,
and the amount,
and the sensitivity, and
density of those receptors
is genetically determined.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And is it true
that if your mother's father
was bald that you will be
bald in the same pattern,
and if he wasn't, you won't?
KYLE GILLETT: That is
a decent correlation.
Part of the proposed
mechanism of this-- well,
there are several genes,
and you can actually
test your genes for hair loss.
You do get a decent amount
of them from your mother.
The unique thing you
get from your mother
that she may have
gotten from her father--
that she got one of the
copies from her father--
is your X chromosome.
And the androgen receptor
gene is on your X chromosome,
so all men got their
androgen receptor
gene from their mother.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's
on their X chromosome,
not on the Y chromosome.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
Even though all of
the, quote, unquote,
male promoting genes are on
the Y chromosome, like malaria,
and inhibiting, et cetera.
Interesting.
So 5 grams a day of creatine
for most people should be fine.
Beneficial for tissue
volumizing-- so strength,
bringing water
into the muscles--
and for the cognitive effects.
And the clinical support
for creatine, I think,
is quite strong at the
5 gram per day dosage.
What other sorts of supplements
can people benefit from?
We already talked
about the omegas
and making sure that people are
getting enough prebiotic fiber
to support the gut
microbiome and vitamin D.
So what other supplement-based
tools can people consider?
KYLE GILLETT: Another one
we can loop in with creatine
is betaine.
Some people are
nonresponders to creatine,
so you can increase
that to 10 grams,
or you can use
its cousin betaine
to help with amino
acid synthesis
and shunting of energy.
Along with that, I would put
l-carnitine which is actually
the smallest peptide hormone.
It's just two amino acids that
are put together, so it's a--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: It's a hormone?
Interesting.
I'm not challenging it.
KYLE GILLETT: Well, peptide.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm just--
I'm not challenging it.
KYLE GILLETT: I would call it
a peptide more than a hormone.
So I would not call
l-carnitine a hormone,
but I would call
dopamine a hormone.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I
could-- a neurohormone.
It's so hard to define things
as transmitters or hormones
at some level.
I agree.
So l-carnitine-- actually,
I should backtrack.
Betaine-- do you recall
what dosage people typically
would take if they're a
creatine non-responder?
KYLE GILLETT: 1 to 3 grams.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Per day?
KYLE GILLETT: In fact--
yeah-- several
versions of creatine
have betaine mixed in because
it helps with the processing
of methionine and homocysteine.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So if somebody
is already taking creatine
and likes it and
responds to it--
I'll raise my hand--
such as myself,
would adding betaine help or
is it redundant with creatine?
KYLE GILLETT: Only
if their homocysteine
is persistently elevated.
And homocysteine is kind of
like an inflammatory marker that
can build up if you're not
converting enough of it
down stream.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
How would I know?
KYLE GILLETT: Just a
blood test or if you
knew your MTHFR
polymorphism, which
is basically how you
add methyl groups
to many things in the body.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Great.
Any side effects of betaine
that people should be aware of?
KYLE GILLETT: Not
that I know of.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: People can
look it up on-- examine.com
is a great site for that.
They'll surely list it.
They just revamped
their site by the way,
and it was awesome before,
and it's platinum now.
So l-carnitine-- what are
the ways to take l-carnitine?
I know that there is
oral forms in capsules
and there's injectables.
The injectables, I think
you need a prescription.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
You need a prescription
for the injectables,
or you should really
get a prescription
for the injectables.
For when you inject it--
of course, at the
supervision of your doctor--
it's usually done
intramuscularly.
It's an aqueous
solution, so it does not
have an oil or a
carrier oil in it
like TR-- like
testosterone esters do.
However, if you inject
it too superficially,
it's not going to make
or break anything.
Often, it just burns if you
inject it subcutaneously
and it does not disseminate
throughout the body as well.
L-carnitine potentially
has localized effects
if you inject it.
If you ingest it orally,
then it has a very low
bioavailability--
maybe only 10%.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well,
I think most people are
going to be able to
get l-carnitine only--
or in its capsule form.
So what are the
dosages of l-carnitine
that one needs to
ingest then if they
want to get a benefit because
if only 10% is being absorbed,
it's probably a
lot of l-carnitine.
How much should
people take per day?
KYLE GILLETT:
Usually, I recommend
for oral l-carnitine
between 1,000 milligrams
and up to 4,000 or
5,000 milligrams.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So 1 to
4-- maybe even 5 grams.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
Up to 5 grams a day.
If you're on that
much, especially
if you have a dysregulated
gut microbiome,
you should be
concerned with TMAO
which is a potential
carcinogen that both carnitine
and choline can convert into.
And your gut
microbiota determine
how much that happens.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Is it true that I
can offset any negative
effects of alpha GPC--
choline that is-- and
l-carnitine that I
take by ingesting garlic?
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: There's a compound
in garlic called allicin--
I believe it's
A-L-L-I-C-I-N. It's also part
of the scientific name-- the
genus of types of garlic.
And this can help decrease
the conversion to TMAO.
Berberine actually slightly
decreases the conversion
to TMAO as well probably
through alteration
of the gut microbiome.
And then just optimizing
your gut microbiome
can decrease conversion.
So not everyone needs
allicin, but it's something
that you should
certainly consider
if you were on a high dose.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm
going to continue
to take the 600 milligrams
of garlic every time
I take my l-carnitine,
but I'm going
to skip the berberine
because berberine gives me
brutal headaches and it makes me
crave carbohydrates because it
drops my blood sugar.
KYLE GILLETT: It has many other
effects, including the dawn
phenomenon where
it drops your blood
sugar when you're sleeping
and you can't even realize it.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I am
not a fan of berberine,
and I'm sorry for
those of you that are.
I'm not trying to offend
anyone, although frankly,
if you're being offended
by my stance on berberine,
then maybe we should
have another discussion.
In any case injectable
l-carnitine,
if one can get that through a
doctor, how much is absorbed
and how much should one take?
KYLE GILLETT: Almost
all of it's absorbed.
In general you're taking
between 500 milligrams up to--
you can take a pretty high
dose up to 2,000 milligrams.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And what
we did not talk about
is what l-carnitine does?
So why should why should
someone go through all of this?
Is it to optimize
testosterone, is it
working on the receptor side?
What's l-carnitine doing?
KYLE GILLETT: It's a shuttle.
So I think it's named
carnitine palmitoyl coenzyme
A. Basically, it
just takes nutrients
from outside your
mitochondria and puts them in.
It also has a unique effect--
well, not too unique
because tadalafil actually
has this effect as well--
is that it increases the
density of the androgen receptor
and the cytoplasm of your cells.
So even if your androgen
receptor sensitivity
doesn't change and even if your
testosterone does not change,
you will have more testosterone
binding to that increased
number of receptors.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Does
one need to cycle
l-carnitine, creatine, betaine?
KYLE GILLETT: No reason
to cycle any of those.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: What
other supplements
can one use to try and
improve hormone profiles?
And here, I realize we're
using a very broad brush
because when we say
improve hormone profiles,
what are we really
talking about?
And for me, at least, I think
about the subjective stuff.
Do people feel
like they are going
to have more energy as
a consequence of doing
these things, are they going to
have the more optimized libido,
or are they going to have
more optimized recovery
from exercise?
Because, I mean,
it's not clear to me
that taking one's
testosterone from 600 to 800
is always going to be a good
thing, especially if estrogen
is increasing in parallel.
That could cause issues.
It could certainly
make things better.
make things worse.
So with that backdrop, what
are some of the other things
people can take?
And then we'll go
back to this issue
of what really is optimization.
KYLE GILLETT: Let's
briefly mention vitamin D,
which is also a hormone.
It's actually a sterile hormone.
And if you have deficient
vitamin D and you replace it,
then you will optimize
your testosterone.
Let's also mention boron.
So if you have a
very high SHBG, boron
can acutely help lower
it usually in a dose
of 5 to 12 milligrams per day.
It's not really a
sustained effect,
but boron is depleted in
soils in many countries.
I believe it's very high in
soils in Greece and Turkey.
So eating dates or raisins
that are from those areas
potentially have more boron.
Boron also might be
one of the reasons
why the reference
range for testosterone
is much higher in those
countries than other countries.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
just to remind people,
that SHBG sex hormone
binding globulin
is attaching to the
testosterone molecule
and limiting the amount of
so-called free testosterone
that's available to have
its impact on cells.
When Dr. Peter Attia
was on this podcast--
in fact, sitting in
that very chair--
he said that the ideal level
of free testosterone in males
should be about 2% of
one's total testosterone.
Would you agree with
that number or disagree?
I'm sure Peter would be
fine if you said either.
[CHUCKLES]
KYLE GILLETT: 2% is
a good rule of thumb.
Usually, the reference range
is between about 1% and 4%.
Some people do have
genetic polymorphisms
in SHBG, a specific
gene mutation where
they have very low SHBGs.
Also men that have varicose
veins in their testes,
also known as varicoceles,
tend to have very high SHBGs,
so that percentage would
likely be less than 2%.
So just because your
percentage of free T to total T
is a little bit above
or below 2%, that's OK.
We just need to figure
out the reason why it is.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
How would somebody
know if they have varicose
veins in their testicles,
especially if their
testicles are still in--
attached to their body?
KYLE GILLETT: Sometimes,
it's hard to tell.
There are several grades.
If you have a grade 3
or a grade 4 varicocele,
it has what's called a
bag of worms appearance.
So think about if you've
just resistance trained,
or it's a really
hot day, or you're
wearing very tight
fitting clothing,
then if you feel it and
almost feels like there's
worms in the scrotum.
The other way is to do--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
That's a scary visual.
KYLE GILLETT:
--yeah, bag of worms.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Well, it
was just that-- yeah, anyway.
I think parasites
when I hear that,
but that's not what
you're referring to.
You're talking about
just the texture.
KYLE GILLETT: The best way
for most people to check
is to valsalva for a
long period of time.
When you valsalva, venous
return will decrease.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Can you
explain valsalva for people?
KYLE GILLETT: It's bearing down
like you're lifting a weight
or having a bowel movement,
where you swallow.
And a lot of times,
you can almost
see build up of blood in
you're jugular veins as well.
So you have decreased
blood return
to the heart and increased
blood in the veins themselves.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'd like
to take a brief break
and thank our sponsor
InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA
to help you better
understand your body
and help you reach
your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular bloodwork done
for the simple reason that
many of the factors that impact
your immediate and
long-term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
The problem with a
lot of blood and DNA
tests out there, however,
is that you get data
back about metabolic factors,
lipids, and hormones,
and so forth, but you don't
know what to do with those data.
InsideTracker
solves that problem
and makes it very easy
for you to understand
what sorts of nutritional,
behavioral, maybe even
supplementation-based
interventions
you might want to
take on in order
to adjust the numbers of those
metabolic factors, hormones,
lipids, and other
things that impact
your immediate and
long-term health to bring
those numbers into the
ranges that are appropriate
and indeed optimal for you.
If you'd like to
try InsideTracker,
you can visit
insidetracker.com/huberman
and get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans.
That's
insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off.
So vitamin D3--
I'm guessing you're
talking about vitamin D3
specifically when
you say vitamin D--
and then boron, 5 to
12 milligrams per day.
And then what are some
of the other things
to optimize testosterone
that are in supplement form?
KYLE GILLETT: We can talk
about things that affect
the steroidogenesis cascade.
So we could touch
on tongkat ali.
I know we've talked about
that a little bit before--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: But I'm
guessing a number of people
probably haven't heard
that conversation.
KYLE GILLETT: Also
known as Long Jack.
And that upregulates
several different enzymes
in the steroidogenesis cascade.
And by that, what you mean if--
and this is another good thing
to Google--
I think anybody interested
in hormone optimization
should understand where
sterile hormones come from.
They come usually
from cholesterol
and they can be shunted off
to vitamin D very easily,
they can be shunted
off to testosterone,
or estrogens, or progestins
quite easily as well.
But tongkat helps
with the conversion
of multiple key steps where
you synthesize testosterone.
Another-- think of it as like
a coenzyme or a cofactor--
an upregulator of these
steps is insulin and IGF-1.
So a good rule of thumb is if
you are not expecting as much
growth hormone,
insulin, and IGF-1--
for example, lower carb
diets, caloric deficits,
you're trying to cut
body fat or body weight--
then tongkat is going to
be theoretically especially
powerful.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: What
sorts of dosages of tongkat
do you recommend
to your patients?
KYLE GILLETT: Anywhere from
300 to 1,200 milligrams a day.
With tongkat, you need
to be careful with
the standardization because--
and if you're thinking about
a general tongkat supplement,
which is by far the
most well-studied--
then you're looking at the
eurycomanone content, which
is a plant compound
that is likely
the main active
pharmacologic effect.
So that's the compound that's
having the effect on the body.
And if you standardize the
eurycomanone very, very high,
then theoretically you're having
more effect at a lower dose.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
take 400 milligrams
of tongkat ali per day.
I take it early in
the day because it
has a bit of a stimulant effect,
and if I take it after 2:00 PM,
it starts to inhibit my sleep.
I've been taking it for years.
And I rather like
that the effects.
It seems subtle but consistent.
I've never cycled it.
Do you recommend cycling it?
KYLE GILLETT: I don't see
any reason to cycle it.
There is a reason to
cycle some supplements,
but no reason to cycle tongkat.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: My
blood work tells me
that it causes an increase
in free testosterone for me
and also a slight increase in
luteinizing hormone for me.
What are some of the other
effects on various hormones
that you've observed in the
bloodwork of your patients
taking tongkat ali?
KYLE GILLETT: Tongkat can
also slightly increase DHEA.
And if you have a
very high SHBG--
again, that's the protein
that binds up your androgens
and estrogens-- an extremely
important protein--
the higher your SHBG, the
more it helps decrease it.
So they've studied
tongkat in populations
with very normal SHBGs and
it does nothing for SHBG.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
Does that mean it does
nothing for somebody overall?
So if somebody has an SHBG
that's in the normal range,
will taking tongkat benefit
them in any other way?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes, it'll
increase their total and free
testosterone.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Got it.
Does it-- is it known to
have effects on anything
else like thyroid
hormone, growth hormone,
or is it purely in these
steroid synthesis pathways?
Or steroid-- I should say
synthesis, and receptor,
and modulation pathways.
KYLE GILLETT: There's no direct
effect on those pathways.
However, any time you alter your
free androgen or free estrogen,
particularly one without
altering the other,
it will alter the
binding protein
that binds thyroid hormones.
So any change you
make, whether it's
natural optimization
or hormone replacement,
you're going to slightly skew
your thyroid hormone profile.
One common actionable example
of this that I see often
clinically is someone
starts, let's say,
estrogen replacement or
testosterone replacement--
maybe they're taking an
AI with their testosterone
replacement--
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Aromatase inhibitor?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct,
an aromatase inhibitor,
which blocks the
conversion to estrogen.
If they're taking
testosterone and they have
very little
estrogen, then you're
going to decrease the
binding protein, also known
as thyroxine binding globulin,
which binds active thyroid
hormones.
So if you start
TRT and you either
have low aromatase activity
or no aromatase activity--
no conversion to estrogen--
then your free thyroid hormones
will go up.
Even just acutely, usually
feedback inhibition,
which is how the body
talks to itself and says,
we need to make more of
this or less of this.
But acutely, there's
not always enough time.
You're going to have very
high thyroid hormones
and you can have tachycardia,
which is a fast heart rate
or you can feel kind
of like overly fight
or flight due to
increased thyroid hormone
activity in the in tissue.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
So tongkat ali--
just a broad range--
300 to 1,200 milligrams per day.
And I realize that the
source matters there.
What are some of
the other hormones
that you prescribe to
your patients who do not
want to go on testosterone
replacement therapy
or take exogenous DHEA
or anything like that?
KYLE GILLETT: We can
talk about fadogia next.
Fadogia is interesting because--
it's a genus of plants.
Fadogia agrestis is one of them.
There's many others that
are very interesting.
That species is likely
the most well-studied,
and it will increase
LH, so I would not
consider it an LH mimetic,
so it doesn't really mimetic.
But it increases the release
of luteinizing hormone
from the pituitary.
That's a hormone that
binds to the Leydig cell
to the LH receptor
kind of like hCG does.
And it will increase the
release of testosterone.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I see.
So I think for people who
aren't familiar with hCG--
so human chorionic
gonadotropin--
is basically synthetic
luteinizing hormone
and luteinizing
hormone is the hormone
released from the
pituitary that is
going to travel
down to the testes
to stimulate the production
of sperm and testosterone,
but mainly testosterone.
Is that correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Mostly correct.
Technically,
synthetic LH is also
known as little r LH,
or recombinant LH.
And hCG can be
synthetic, but often, it
is just refined from the
urine of pregnant ladies
since the placenta makes it.
That's why it's called
chorionic gonadotropin.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So where are they
getting all this
pregnant women's urine?
I mean, there a location?
I mean, not that I want
to go there, I just--
KYLE GILLETT: Donation?
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --really--
so there are women that--
KYLE GILLETT: First
trimester pregnant ladies.
It's very high.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Donating their urine,
and then they're purifying it,
and then men are injecting it?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Wow.
KYLE GILLETT: And
that's actually
the same for menopausal ladies.
So first trimester
pregnant ladies,
that's how you can
make non-synthetic hCG.
And then for menotropins
which are also known--
there's a couple of different
names for it, like menopur.
You have menopausal ladies
that have very high LH and FSH,
and then you refine
the FSH and LH.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So moving
away from the sources
and from urine, Fadogia
agrestis, what dosages
do you have patients take?
I've heard of some
potential toxicity
to the testicular cells.
KYLE GILLETT: There
is one study--
and this is a rat study, but you
can equate the dose of toxicity
in rats and humans.
They did not give these
rats any antioxidants,
but it increases a couple
of different proinflammatory
markers.
One is GGT, or gamma
glutamate transferase.
It comes from both the
testes and the liver,
and one is alkaline phosphatase,
also known as Alkphos, again,
coming from both areas.
There are several
different ways that you
can attenuate this increase.
And you can also just check
to see if you have increased.
In the rat dose that equates
with humans that had no
effect-- so the safe dose--
was an average of
300 milligrams a day.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So that
would be 300 milligrams a day
in humans is the dosage
that did not have toxicity.
Correct?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
And often, even if there
is toxicity in rats,
there is not toxicity in humans.
So it's not directly
equitable, but to be safe,
another regimen that I have
people take is 600 milligrams
every other day
or 600 milligrams
three times a week-- often
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: This is very
interesting and relevant,
because I've been taking
fadogia for some period of time.
All my markers
and tests indicate
that there's no toxicity.
But I've been taking
600 milligrams per day,
but I've been cycling it for
about 8 to 12 weeks on and then
a few weeks off.
But based on what
you're saying, I'm
thinking maybe three times
per week or every other day
might be better.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: If you weren't
going to get any labs,
that is certainly the
regimen that you want.
If you're going to check
your GGT and ALK phos,
or even take other things to
prevent those from increasing,
then you can certainly be more
aggressive with your fadogia
dosing.
You can increase it
quite a bit, and it
has a dose dependent response in
both the activities associated
with high testosterone and
also just LH and testosterone.
So the more aggressive
regimen would
be 600 milligrams
daily for a month
and then take one
to two weeks off.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Great.
I think that's more or
less what I've been doing.
Terrific.
In terms of other
hormones, what are
some of the supplements that
can support growth hormone--
a hormone that's
associated with tissue
repair and, in some cases,
metabolism and fat loss?
What are some of the
tools, nutritional and/or
supplement-based, one can do
to tap on the growth hormone
pathway?
And let's lump
IGF-1 in there too
since they're
essentially working
along the same dimensions.
KYLE GILLETT: A quick
synopsis-- growth hormone
is a peptide hormone, and it
is released by the pituitary.
There's growth hormone
releasing hormone and ghrelin
that stimulate the release.
So there's also peptides that
are very analogous to these two
things.
You have that
pulsatile secretion
of growth hormone in a very
fast half life of just minutes,
and then it increases IGF-1.
There is both peripheral IGF-1
and central IGF-1 and IGF2,
but no need to get
into the specifics.
There is a happy medium to
where your growth hormone is
at an adequate level and your
IGF-1 is an adequate level.
Usually, those
two are congruent.
So in most cases, we just check
an IGF-1 and, occasionally,
the binding peptides
for IGF-1 kind
of like SHBG that we
talked about earlier,
but you're estimating
a free IGF-1.
It's kind of confusing
because all hormone--
almost all hormones have binding
proteins to help regulate them.
But often, you want to
look at free testosterone,
free estradiol, free IGF-1--
or at least estimate
it-- free cortisol even,
and free thyroid hormone.
But when you're talking about
growth hormone and IGF-1,
usually you don't need to
do anything to optimize it.
If you are diabetic,
then-- and depending
on the type of diabetes,
your IGF-1 and growth hormone
can be too high.
Specifically, in
type 1 diabetes,
your growth hormone is extremely
high, but your IGF-1 is low.
So if you're in a dysregulated
state or have pathology,
I would just talk to your doctor
about IGF-1 or growth hormone.
Taking amino acids
before you go to bed
could potentially help
with growth hormone release
just because most growth hormone
is released while you sleep.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I've
heard that fasting
can increase growth hormone.
And I know there are certain
patterns of weight training
that can increase
growth hormone.
Some of those regimens
in the weight room
that increase growth hormone
have been covered by Dr. Duncan
French, who was a
guest on this podcast,
and so maybe we'll refer
people to that episode
for the specific protocols--
these high volume training.
KYLE GILLETT: During
those training exercises,
it usually does it transiently
for a period of a few hours.
And a lot of this IGF-1 is
released by the muscle itself.
So it's not necessarily
released by the liver.
IGF-1 that is released
directly due to growth hormone
signaling-- usually, the
growth hormone comes from
the pituitary and binds to
the liver where usually,
it has a half life
of about a week,
where the paracrine
or autocrine--
think of it as like the
peripherally acting or acting
in the muscles itself,
which is also helpful--
is released and is not as
concerning because it's not
related to insulin
resistance, but it is
related to the training itself.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So fasting
and growth hormone--
is it true that fasting can
increase growth hormone?
And maybe as a little
related tangent,
I've heard that limiting
food intake for the two hours
before going to
sleep can increase
the pulse of growth hormone that
one experiences during sleep.
Of course, everyone gets a pulse
of growth hormone during sleep,
but especially
carbohydrate-laden meals
can blunt that peak that
occurs during sleep quite
substantially.
So two questions-- does avoiding
food intake in the two hours
prior to sleep help increase
growth hormone release?
Maybe it's being
overly neurotic.
Maybe people need to avoid food
in the four hours before sleep.
But regardless, what is the
relationship between fasting
and growth hormone release?
I find this really interesting.
KYLE GILLETT: Fasting
certainly potently increases
growth hormone release.
However, the IND binding to
the receptor is less sensitive.
So although fasting does
increase growth hormone,
the genes that are
downstream to it--
both the growth
hormone genes and IGF-1
related gene transcription
activity-- will not
be significantly higher.
However, if you are optimizing
the growth hormone that
is released as a
pulsatile secretion,
it is helpful to avoid
eating for two hours.
So the general rule of thumb
is avoid eating about two hours
before bed.
I think that's clinically
significant and helpful.
But fasting otherwise
specifically for growth hormone
optimization in
someone who already
has normal growth hormone
signaling is not helpful.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
That's extremely useful
to hear because one
of the major reasons
why people fast is to get
that growth hormone increase.
But if they're adjusting things
on the backend that negate
that, well, then, no such luck.
Not that I have anything
against fasting.
I do a pseudointermittent
fasting mostly
because I prefer to eat at
fairly regular times of day.
So it doesn't sound
like there's a lot
that people can take
in supplement form
to improve growth hormone.
What about thyroid hormone?
What are some of the things that
people can take or do in order
to make sure that their thyroid
hormone levels are appropriate?
KYLE GILLETT: You want to
have a balance of iodine
and you want to have a
good source of iodine.
So there are some
camps that say you
should use a huge
high dose of iodine
and there's protocols for it.
And there are some that say you
should use just barely enough
iodine--
I believe it's like
200 micrograms per day.
But you want to balance.
One of the things that I
see that many people do not
talk about when it comes
to iodine and thyroid
is there's compounds
known as goitrogens.
And these goitrogens are
neither good nor evil,
but they're actually kind
of a nice check and balance.
You need more iodine if you
consume more goitrogens.
And some examples of these are
some of my favorite foods--
cruciferous vegetables.
Boron is also a goitrogen.
So higher goitrogens,
higher iodine.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So ingesting iodine
containing salt is useful?
Yes or no?
KYLE GILLETT: Iodized
salt does prevent goiter,
but it is not necessarily
the ideal form of iodine.
Good forms of iodine
often come from the ocean.
If you look at a chart
of hypothyroidism,
there is a tendency to have
more hypothyroidism the more
inland you go.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So trying to
eat some cruciferous vegetables
each day would be the best way
to improve thyroid hormone.
KYLE GILLETT: Along
with plenty of iodine.
You don't want too
much iodine signaling.
Many people are familiar with
radioactive iodine tablets,
and that's basically an
extremely high amount of iodine
to block out the
radioactive iodine that
comes from after like a
nuclear meltdown or whatnot.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So we've got
creatine, betaine, l-carnitine,
with allicin garlic
to offset the TMAO.
Vitamin D3, boron, tongkat
ali, fadogia, some fasting.
I'd love to talk to
you about peptides.
So I can imagine a hierarchy.
A hierarchy starts with
behaviors and nutrition.
Behaviors, of course,
includes training,
and limiting stress, and all the
things we talked about before--
sunshine et cetera--
and optimize nutrition.
Then, we talked
about supplements--
all the things we just listed
off to optimize testosterone.
And we can get into
this, but estrogen
as well, which is important
for libido, and brain
function, and tissue function,
and joints feeling good, et
cetera.
But then we get into the realm
where one might, or could
consider, exogenous hormones.
Get-- taking a small
dose of testosterone
or taking a small dose of GH
even if that were appropriate
and certainly only
working with a doctor.
But in between, there's a
step of so-called peptides.
And of course, there
are many peptides.
We've already talked
about some of them.
But when people talk
about taking peptides,
the ones that I hear
most often about
is a category that
increases GH and IGF-1,
and those to my knowledge go by
the things like sermorelin sort
of a kit of things that
are taken separately
or in combination to
increase GH and IGF-1.
But then other
people, for instance,
are taking peptides like
BPC 157 to try and improve
tissue healing and recovery.
There's a lot of
interest in peptides.
Please, if you would,
tell us about what
you know about the
safety of peptides
in terms of their sourcing
and the utility of peptides.
Is this something that people
should consider before thinking
about hormone replacement?
Should people be
wary of these things?
I am very wary of
particular sources that are
sold online that are not clean.
They contain contaminants
and that could be dangerous.
I really would love your
thoughts on peptides.
So I'm just going to sit back
and let you riff on peptides,
but if you could touch on some
of the ones that I mentioned,
I'd be most grateful.
KYLE GILLETT: A
peptide is just a chain
of amino acids between two and
a couple hundred in length.
So I think of peptides as
several different categories.
And the GHRPs that
you mentioned,
I would consider those--
and that stands for Growth
Hormone Releasing Peptide.
You have two main types--
the ghrelin agonist that
are-- or they hit the ghrelin
receptor, and it helps release
growth hormone because of that.
And then also the
GHRH-like peptides.
So they're very similar to
growth hormone releasing
hormone.
Often, they just change
a couple amino acids,
and it acts like that.
Tesamorelin is one of them,
sermorelin is another one,
and CJC is another common one.
I believe those are all in the
class of GHRH-like peptides,
whereas ipamorelin or
ibutamoren, which is also
known as MK-677, those two
are in the class of ghrelin
agonist.
So they're more like
they hit the receptor
that ghrelin does whereas
the other ones hit the GHRH
receptor.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I think of
ghrelin as making me hungry.
KYLE GILLETT: Hungry and angry.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Why would I want
to take something that would
increase ghrelin signaling?
KYLE GILLETT: Some people
are trying to gain weight.
It also does increase
your growth hormone.
So if your growth hormone is
very low, you can consider it.
Ibutamoren is a long-acting--
so it has a long half life, also
known as MK-677.
It was well-- it
was studied mostly
in growth hormone deficiency.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And do
these people get angry also?
KYLE GILLETT: They can.
Many people report a
side effect of anxiety
or significant hunger.
Most people take
it in the evening
so they don't notice
that hunger as much.
It can also greatly
increase your blood glucose.
So if you're insulin
resistant or pre-diabetic,
it gets especially concerning.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: This is one of
those rare moments where I hear
something and I think, even
though there is this kit
of compounds that can
increase GH and IGF-1,
based on everything
you're telling me,
maybe just taking GH is the
better option for those people,
because growth hormone,
at least it's--
synthetic growth
hormone is mimicking
an endogenous hormone.
I mean, certainly not taking
anything might be the ideal.
But for those that want
to increase growth hormone
and they want to
use pharmacology
to do that, it sounds like these
peptides are pretty precarious.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah, it kind
of depends on the situation.
If there's an individual
that struggles with hunger
and not eating enough--
for example, someone who has
a very small stomach or they
just have a very
low hunger drive,
sometimes you want more of
that orexigenic signaling.
The hypothalamus, you have
anorexia signaling, which
is kind of like anorexia,
and orexigenic signaling,
which is--
I call it the hangry
center of the hypothalamus
or the hangry center.
And if there's an imbalance
between those two, then
perhaps it'd be helpful.
Potentially theoretically
helpful in anorexics, of which,
the incidence of anorexia in
men is increasing significantly.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: As
you're telling me this,
I'm remembering being
14 or 15 years old,
and I would go into
the kitchen sometimes,
and I was so hungry I would
just obliterate all the food.
And I do remember being--
I've always been a
pretty high energy guy,
but having an immense
amount of energy.
I can't recall if it was
a hangry feeling or not,
but I'm guessing that
was growth hormone.
I grew one foot in a
single academic year,
so I imagine that was at least
in part due to growth hormone.
In any case, sermorelin
is the peptide
that I hear most often about.
I admittedly tried a run of it.
I was researching
a book, and decided
to take it before sleep
on an empty stomach.
It gave me a tremendous
depth of sleep,
but that sleep was
really truncated,
which is just nerd speak for
saying deep but short sleep.
I would wake up after
very intense dreams.
I can't say that it helped
me recover from exercise that
much.
I didn't notice any additional
fat loss or anything.
Sort of abandoned it
except for occasional use.
Again, this was
prescribed by a doctor.
I'm starting to get the
sense that these peptides
and their effects are somewhat
vague, and distributed,
and highly individual.
Is that a fair way
to describe them?
KYLE GILLETT: Part
of the problem
with the effect of peptides
is many people take them
and levels that are far
above the physiologic range.
Even individuals who are
checking their IGF-1 while they
take these different
GHRPs, most of them
do not check the binding
peptides-- for example,
IGF binding peptide 1, 2, or 3.
And their free IGF-1 level might
be significantly different.
So common doses that people
will take these off-label
for as a supplement
are often much greater
than the therapeutic
or physiologic range.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Which, for
me, just underscores the fact
that it's pretty precarious.
I mean, I'm not coming in
here as the referee of what
anyone should or shouldn't do.
I'm just trying to gather
and distribute information.
But I've heard, for instance,
that some companies where
people can acquire these
things without prescription,
those companies are not
good at cleaning out
the lipopolysaccharide--
the LPS--
which can cause an
inflammatory response.
In other words, these
are dirty compounds.
And that just sounds risky.
It just sounds--
frankly, it just
sounds really dangerous to me.
KYLE GILLETT: LPS is a common
additive in many companies
that are not
pharmacies, but they're
selling things that people
often use as human consumption.
One interesting note
about lipopolysaccharide
is your gut microbiome actually
makes a lot of it as well,
especially prevotella which
is a specific species, that
can have to do with your
baseline body temperature.
So your baseline
body temperature
might also change depending
on if you're on a peptide that
has LPS in it.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yikes,
yikes, and yikes.
[CHUCKLES] But I tend to
be pretty conservative
when it comes to taking
anything exogenous.
But I do rely on many
of the supplements
that we talked about earlier
and I do try and optimize
the behavioral things
and nutritional things
for a long time.
So then leaving
peptides behind, we
are now I suppose in the
territory of exogenous hormone.
So let's say that
somebody decides
they're not concerned
with fertility,
or they're going to bank sperm,
or they already have kids,
or they're going to defer
on this issue of wanting
to have kids, my
understanding is
that nowadays, a lot of people
are using testosterone--
let's not even
call it replacement
therapy, because some of
these people have 600, 700,
or even 800 nanogram
per deciliter read.
So they're not replacing
anything that is diminished.
They're just trying to
augment what's already there--
increase what's already there.
My understanding is that taking
a low dose more frequently
is going to be more beneficial
than the kind of old school
way of giving 100 or
even 200 milligrams
in a single injection
once every two weeks.
Is that right?
And what do you do
with your patients?
So let me give you
a hypothetical.
Somebody comes into your office,
they do their blood work,
and they have blood
levels of, let's say,
600 nanogram per
deciliter testosterone.
Their estrogen is
also in normal range.
Everything else checks
out, but they're
complaining of slightly
diminished libido, slightly
poor recovery from workouts,
maybe reduced motivation
and drive, although
no major depression.
And you come to the conclusion
that testosterone therapy--
not replacement, but
testosterone therapy
might be a good
option to explore.
What's a typical dosage
range and frequency
of administration range that
you might consider exploring?
KYLE GILLETT: And some of
this depends on the SHBG
and free testosterone as well.
So if that same individual had
a very high SHBG which, again,
is the binding
protein that binds up
the testosterone and all
androgens and estrogens,
if it is extremely
high and they have
a free testosterone
of two, then they
might need a different
dose because they
need enough
testosterone in order
to have a normal eugonadal
free testosterone.
But a general normal dosing
range, especially for someone
starting, is around
100 to 120 milligrams
divided over the course
of a week, usually
either every other day or three
times a week-- occasionally,
twice a week.
Many people with
SHBG a bit higher
can get away pretty
easily with twice a week.
This is assuming that the ester
is cypionate or enanthate.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So two
60 milligram injections
of testosterone
cypionate per week.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah,
very common dosing.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: To hit
that 120 milligrams per week
is kind of the typical average.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
And I would consider this like
a physiologic eugonadal dose.
For many people, even
200 milligrams a week
is far above the
reference range.
All of this is said
with the caveat
that testosterone is normally
released in a pulsatile manner.
So it's high in the
morning, low in the evening.
Whereas if you're on
testosterone therapy,
then you're going to
have a steady state.
So your testosterone
level is going
to be pretty much the
same even in the evening.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And
in your experience,
when patients do
that, I'm guessing
they report that
normal constellation
of positive effects--
improved mood, improved energy,
improve sleep, recovery,
et cetera.
What are some of the
hazards or things that
can crop up in bloodwork
or just subjectively
that can be warning signs
that even a dosage of 120
milligrams divided into these
two or three dosages per week
is too high?
KYLE GILLETT: Every
organ system in the body.
So this is when you
really have to be
at least well-versed in
every organ system, not just
the gonadal genital system.
You need to have
dermatology prowess.
Acne is very common change.
Lots of different skin
pathologies or even bruising
can be related to
hormone replacement.
Hair loss is very
common to see as well.
Mental status changes.
It could occasionally
even induce
as a manic or a bipolar episode
because testosterone is also
dopaminergic.
And then a cardiovascularly
not just in the heart,
but also concerns for like
microvascular ischemic disease.
Ferritin buildup because
the estrogen also increases.
And then fertility concerns as
well and lipid concerns too.
So you really have to be
hematologist, dermatologist,
cardiologist, lipidologist,
the whole 9 yards.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So another reason--
or set of reasons
rather to, if one
is considering using
testosterone therapy,
to really do this in
close communication
with a really good
physician because that's
a lot to monitor.
Knowing whether or not you
have acne or not is one thing,
but knowing whether or
not your LDL is going up,
your ApoB is going up,
that's a whole other biz
and that needs to be
done through bloodwork
is what I'm hearing.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
And if your physician that
is managing or prescribing
your testosterone
therapy or your HRT
is not well-versed
in these systems,
you would want him
or her to be part
of an interdisciplinary
team where
they have other experts that
can monitor those systems.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
skipped over a sort
of still intermediate set of
things-- prescription drugs--
but maybe talking
about testosterone
first was a bit of
a mistake on my part
because I'm aware that
there are-- actually,
I think there are companies,
but certainly groups out there
that say, no, wait-- don't
go straight from nothing
to supplements to testosterone.
Once you're doing
behaviors and optimizing
nutrition supplements--
let's forget peptides--
instead of going straight
to testosterone therapy, one
idea that many people are
pursuing is to take the
prescription drugs that trigger
luteinizing hormones--
so taking hCG--
human chorionic gonadotropin,
which my understanding is
will increase testosterone,
but also estrogen.
Or they'll take things
like clomiphene.
In fact, I think there are a
bunch of companies out there
now that are saying don't take
testosterone-- it shuts down
spermatogenesis, it shuts
down testosterone production--
clomiphene is the way to go.
Maybe you could educate us
about the hCG monotherapy,
I think it's called, where
you're just mono-- one--
just taking hCG and
clomiphene as a--
and/or clomiphene as a tool
to ratchet up hormones.
KYLE GILLETT: So a
quick points on hCG--
human chorionic
gonadotropin-- made
during especially the first
trimester of pregnancy,
it has effects other than
binding to the LH receptor.
It also binds to the TSH
receptor in the thyroid.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So it's
thyroid stimulating hormone?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
In fact, if you look at a
molecule of hCG and thyroid
stimulating hormone, they
are extremely similar.
However, you need a
relatively high dose of hCG
to bind to the TSH receptor.
This is the normal
mechanism in pregnancy
that accounts for the increased
need of thyroid hormone--
usually, about 30% to 40%.
So that's why if someone
has hypothyroidism,
you increase their
dose of thyroid,
because the hCG is not going
to be doing it for you.
The Clomid, or clomiphene,
there's two main--
I believe it's diastereomers.
And one of them is
enclomiphene and one of them
is zuclomiphene.
And these two work
slightly differently.
Enclomiphene, I believe,
has a faster half life
and it is potentially
slightly better tolerated.
However, they were studying it--
Clomid is a very
commonly prescribed drug,
and obviously, there is plenty
of enclomiphene in Clomid.
However, the drug which
was Andrew androxal--
A-N-D-R-O-X-A-L-- did not go
all the way through the FDA
approval process despite
Clomid being FDA approved.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So there's Clomid
which contains clomiphene,
but there are also--
because we're talking about
male hormone optimization
this episode-- there
are males out there
who want to increase their
testosterone and other
hormones-- maybe growth hormone,
et cetera-- who opt to not take
exogenous testosterone-- so
no cream, no pellet, no pill,
no injectable cypionate--
but decide to take clomiphene
a couple of times a week.
My understanding--
I've never done this.
I would say if I had.
My understanding is
that taking clomiphene--
maybe two 50 milligram
tablets a week
is what I hear
people are doing--
will increase what--
luteinizing hormone,
the various estrogen
receptor subunits?
Could you explain how
clomiphene would benefit anyone,
and is this a good strategy?
I'm hearing that it's
being done quite a lot now.
KYLE GILLETT: It will
increase testosterone
in a dose dependent
manner, but it
has many other
pharmacodynamic effects, which
is the effect of
the drug on the body
other than its effect on the
hypothalamus and the pituitary.
So in the hypothalamus
and the pituitary,
it does what's called negative
feedback inhibition or it
blocks the action of estrogen.
So it crowds out estrogen
from the estrogen receptor
on the hypothalamus
and the pituitary.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And what's
this objective effect
that would cause?
So to my understanding
and experience of estrogen
is that if I ever
took-- and I did
take a very low dose of an
aromatase inhibitor once
and I felt terrible.
Actually reduced libido,
joints felt achy.
That's when I discovered that,
wow, estrogen is actually
really important for your brain
function, for joint function,
and for libido.
And suppressing
estrogen, for me, it just
turned out to be the wrong idea.
But my levels indicate that
it's within reference range.
So why would I want
to take something
that would increase the activity
of an estrogen receptor?
I just can't find the
rationale for that.
KYLE GILLETT: The main
rationale behind taking
a serm is as a very
temporary measure that is not
going to suppress pituitary
or hypothalamic function
if your testosterone is just
so drastically low that it
is unlikely to recover anyway.
So most of the time it
is not clinically useful,
and serm should
not be prescribed
very often, certainly not
as long term testosterone
replacement or testosterone
optimization in most
individuals.
There's always
exceptions to everything.
But there's five
different estrogen
and estrogen-related receptors.
There's two main
estrogen receptors.
And clomid and every serm
has a very unique profile
because they selectively inhibit
some receptors in some tissues,
but not other receptors
in other tissues.
For example, Clomid can inhibit
receptors that are in the eye,
and it can cause visual changes,
blurry vision, especially
at higher doses.
And it also acts in every
other tissue of the body.
So a side effects from Clomid
and other selective estrogen
receptor modifiers
are very common.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
So I'm at least--
by my mind, I'm going to
pool them with peptides
and say it sounds precarious
and probably not ideal
for most people.
Going back to testosterone
therapy then-- and notice,
folks, I've deleted
the replacement part
because I think so many people
are using testosterone therapy
without the need to-- the
sort of reference range
need to replace
anything, but rather are
building on what they already
have for purposes of increasing
vitality, et cetera.
Going back to that,
my understanding
is that taking hCG
several times per week
can help maintain
spermatogenesis and fertility
even while people
are on testosterone.
But-- and you and I were
talking about this earlier--
that there's
tremendous variation.
Some people will take a
small amount testosterone
and just crush
their sperm count.
They just won't make
any viable sperm.
Other people can maintain
viable sperm production
while on testosterone,
especially
if they're taking hCG.
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
And there's many
reasons for this.
Some of this has to do with
heat damage to the testes,
so potentially cold therapy
could be helpful for that.
And--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Ice
baths, cold showers?
KYLE GILLETT: Mhm.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Yeah, or just avoid--
and certainly avoiding--
KYLE GILLETT: Mostly
avoiding heat.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
--sauna and hot tub.
Yeah.
KYLE GILLETT: Stopping
the daily hot tub
can restore fertility
in many people.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I
know a number of people
that are trying to
conceive children that
go into the sauna,
and they'll just
put a cold pack in their shorts
or between their legs depending
on whether or not they're
wearing shorts or not
when they go in.
Or they'll alternate
ice and heat
in a way that maintains
coolness of the milieu
in which the sperm live.
In other words, they're cooling
their scrotum deliberately
in order to avoid
killing the sperm.
Actually, I saw an
interesting paper
that said that for every two
degree increase in temperature
of the scrotum, there's a 20%
decrease in spermatogenesis
and viability of sperm.
And that actually, if you
look at the difference
between people who
stand a lot, sit a lot,
and drive a lot, what you see is
a progressive decrease in sperm
count because when
people are sitting,
there's an increase
in temperature,
and then when they're sitting
on the hot seat of the car,
there's an-- or using
the heated seats,
actually, it kills sperm.
I think there are
good data on that.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah,
excellent data,
and anecdotally,
you see it as well.
I've had several patients come
in for fertility consultations.
And all we do is like, no
medications, no supplements.
We change their--
several lifestyle things.
Very tight fitting
clothing is another one.
And soon, they have fertility
again and they're no longer--
they have sperm whereas
before, they did not.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
I'd like to talk about some
of the do's and don'ts, but we
have talked about a lot of
do's-- things that one can do
to optimize hormones.
Maybe we could just do sort
of more rapid fire Q&A on some
of the don'ts and maybe throw
in some science where you feel
it's appropriate.
Cannabis, marijuana,
THC-- yes or no--
it diminishes
testosterone levels?
KYLE GILLETT: Smoked
cannabis, I would say,
diminishes testosterone,
increases prolactin.
That's a no.
Other cannabinoids, not
particularly harmful.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So CBD?
KYLE GILLETT: CBD, not
particularly harmful.
Smoked CBD, I'm not sure.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: What about
edible cannabis and THC?
KYLE GILLETT: As far as I
know, edible cannabis and THC
does not significantly
increase prolactin to a point
where it would be
disruptive of hormones.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Can
marijuana, THC, cannabis,
whatever you want to call
it, increase gynecomastia--
the growth of male
breast tissue?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes,
it certainly can,
and there's a pretty good
association between smoked THC
and gynecomastia.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: What about
nicotine and testosterone
and estrogen and other
hormones-- smoked nicotine?
KYLE GILLETT: Nicotine
is particularly
concerning not only for
testosterone, but also
for estrogen. Part of it is, if
you're talking about nicotine
from tobacco, there's many
other carcinogens in it,
especially if it's smoked.
But nicotine, even
if it is chewed
in a dose dependent manner--
so if you can use an extremely
small amount of nicotine,
then it's not as
concerning in the long run.
But it's a
vasoconstrictor, and one
of the main concerns with it
would be cardiovascular disease
or even microvascular
ischemic disease that
can lead to
neurodegenerative disease,
so like a type of dementia that
can be partly due to nicotine.
If you use nicotine for a
very long period of time,
especially at a
higher dose, it's
a dose-dependent effect
on your hormone profile.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Is that
also true for Nicorette
and other nicotine gums?
KYLE GILLETT: At
high doses, if you
can use an extremely low
dose of a nicotine gum,
then theoretically, that
would be maintainable.
It's not going to overload
the nicotinic receptor.
You have acetylcholine
and the cholinergic system
is one of your main
nervous systems, of course.
And you have
muscarinic receptors
and nicotinic receptors,
and there's just
better ways to optimize your
nicotinic receptor activity.
For example,
acetylcholine precursors
like alpha GPC,
phosphatidylserine,
phosphatidylcholine.
Weak acetylcholinesterase
inhibitors,
especially natural
ones, potentially
have a part as well.
And then other alkaloids.
So nicotine is an alkaloid
from the tobacco plant.
There are other
plants like cytosine
and that genus of plants,
and that alkaloid is also
a nicotine receptor agonist.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Is it true
that cycling for too long--
literally, bicycling-- sitting
on a bike seat too long
can damage the prostate?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes, it
can be very concerning,
especially if you're seated
while cycling, especially
if you're putting a lot of
pressure on the perineum.
Your core is kind
of like a box where
your diaphragm sort of makes the
top and your abs and serratus
make the front and the sides.
Your back muscles make the
back, and then your pelvic floor
makes the bottom
of the box, which
is arguably the most
important part of your core.
And that pressure
can weaken and even
lead to incontinence
and impotence.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So we
were talking earlier today
in the gym about how
heavy legwork, hack
squats, deadlifts, those
kinds of things a lot of guys
are doing to increase their
testosterone, done correctly,
can actually
augment and build up
the strength of
the pelvic floor.
Done incorrectly, can actually
weaken the pelvic floor
and lead to all sorts of issues,
including sexual effects--
negative sexual effects.
So how does one go about
learning whether or not
their movements are
being done properly
to support pelvic floor or
to destruct pelvic floor?
KYLE GILLETT: The pelvic
floor is a constellation
of muscles just
like any other kind
of like system in the body.
And form is important.
If you're doing the valsalva
maneuver, which again,
is that bearing down or deep
breath where you feel all
of your abs are
tight, you can also
notice that your pelvic
floor is tight as well.
If you have a history of
an inguinal hernia, which
is a hole kind of like
connecting the abdominal cavity
down through the
pelvic floor or even
the scrotum in some
cases-- and that
can be a sign that there
is weakness in that area,
and you might have
to concentrate it
on it most, or even
have a physiotherapist
or a physical
therapist specifically
target the pelvic floor.
Many exercises in which
you valsalva or use
your glutes or
legs, you can learn
to squeeze them and have that
mind-muscle connection in order
to help build up
the pelvic floor.
And there's other things.
Many people are
familiar with kegels.
That is just one of the
many different exercises
that can help your pelvic floor.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
My understanding
is that while strengthening
the pelvic floor is good,
excessive contraction
of the pelvic floor
can actually limit blood flow
to the pelvic area, the penis,
and so forth.
So this is, again, a
double-edged sword.
I mean, you don't
want guys out there
to just start doing endless
number of kegels every day
because they're actually
going to constrict
blood flow to that area.
There's-- and in fact,
the erection response is
parasympathetic.
It's a relaxed induced
response, right?
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So for the--
the reason I chuckle is that
for--
because we're
talking about things,
we don't have visuals or
charts, and certainly, it's
hard to know whether or not
a given exercise like kegels
are going to be
good or not good.
If it's excessive, what--
how many sets and reps
does it take before it
goes from good to bad.
Is there a kind of
general rule of thumb
for people to think about this?
I mean, clearly blood
flow to that area
is key for sexual performance.
And yet when one trains
the legs or even walks,
you're getting blood flow.
So my understanding is this
that a combination of weight
training to stimulate
the positive hormonal,
and muscular, and
connective tissue growth
is key provided it's
not overtraining,
but so is casual exercise
like walking, and stretching,
and the sorts of
things that will then
return blood flow to that area.
Is that an overly basic
way to think about it
or will that suffice?
KYLE GILLETT: I think that's
a good way to think about it.
I think the main
point with kegels
is they're just one of
many different things.
So if you're having some
pelvic floor pathology
certainly or even just concerned
about your pelvic floor,
don't just take the advice
do kegels and you'll be OK.
That is not near enough.
It's just one of
the many aspects.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So going
back to the rapid Q&A,
and then we'll come back
to this issue of blood flow
because there's some interesting
science and protocols there--
the question I have
is, alcohol, does it
increase aromatase, the enzyme
that converts testosterone
into estrogen or not?
And is there a dose
dependence there?
KYLE GILLETT: It
significantly does.
There is a dose dependence.
In general, I would not
recommend more than three
to four standard drinks.
One huge glass of wine is
probably five standard drinks.
But I'd say every two weeks.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah,
that's consistent with what
I discovered researching
alcohol in an episode we
did on alcohol.
That no alcohol is definitely
better for all aspects
of health than any alcohol.
And anyone that says that,
well, red wine contains
these various things,
well, it doesn't
contain enough of
those positive things
to have a positive effect.
But that if people do
opt to drink alcohol,
that two drinks per week--
and meaning 20 grams of alcohol,
so that's probably two 12 ounce
beers or two 4 ounce
glasses of wine--
is going to be the upper
limit beyond which you're
going to start seeing all
sorts of negative effects.
KYLE GILLETT: The other thing to
keep in mind with alcohol is it
has a lot of calories--
seven kilocalories
per gram, almost as
much as fat, which is 9.
And then it's also
very GABAergic,
so it can activate
inhibitory neurotransmission,
and that can also affect how
much LH and FSH is released.
So that can also
decrease testosterone
almost kind of
similar to how opiates
can decrease testosterone.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And I feel
very lucky that I don't enjoy
alcohol-- never really did.
I can kind of take
it or leave it.
I certainly don't like sedatives
like Valium or anything
like that, which, as
you just mentioned,
can suppress testosterone.
You said the word fat, so
I'm going to pick up on that
and say, in order to
optimize hormone production,
is it important to have some
saturated fat in one's diet?
And what happens on very low
fat diets to testosterone,
and estrogen, and
other steroid hormones?
KYLE GILLETT: Fat is
interesting because there are so
many different beneficial fats.
Omega 3s-- almost every American
gets plenty of omega 6s--
in any developed country really.
When it comes to
saturated fat, there
is more of a correlation
with hormone optimisation.
If you're eating things
with saturated fat,
you tend to have--
those are things with more fat
soluble vitamins and things
that are very nutrient
dense otherwise.
But it is not vital.
In general, you want to
eliminate any trans fat
unless it's trans fat
from the ruminants.
There's always an
exception to everything.
So there are healthy
trans omega 3 fats, which
are formed in the
stomach of grass fed
and finished ruminants.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: But
ingesting mostly olive oils,
maybe nut butters in limited
amounts because they're
very calorie dense, but--
unless people are trying
to increase their calories,
in which case,
they're a great source
of calories, small amounts
of butter, ghee, probably OK,
but not excessive amounts?
Is that the idea?
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
Fat is perfectly fine.
Cholesterol has an interesting--
so cholesterol and, in general,
phospholipids make the bilayer
that's around the cell.
But cholesterol is also a
hormone in and of itself
because it binds to the
estrogen-related receptor
alpha.
So I consider that like in the
estrogen receptor category,
and that can help
with metabolism,
but also potentially
have concerns
for cancer and tumor risk.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I want
to go back to the prostate
and talk to you about
something that's
kind of a newer emerging trend.
I know that you've talked
a little bit about this
in previous podcasts, that a
number of men-- or I should say
a number of physicians
are prescribing
low dose tadalafil,
also known as Cialis,
to their male patients.
So in dosage ranges of like
2.5 milligrams to 5 milligrams
per day, but not for
erectile dysfunction,
but rather for improving
prostate health.
And presumably, they get sort of
a boost in terms of blood flow
to the genitalia as well.
But again, not specifically to
deal with erectile dysfunction,
but to deal with prostate health
and blood flow to the prostate.
Is that something
that you sometimes--
often prescribe to your
patients, and of what age?
KYLE GILLETT: Tadalafil is a
very underrated medication.
The age would kind of
depend on the indication.
So tadalafil is also a
blood pressure medication.
It can very slightly
decrease blood pressure,
especially at higher doses.
At higher doses, it--
a high dose would be 20
milligrams, not 2.5 milligrams.
But consistently,
it can somewhat
affect with the cones
in the eye that have
to do with red and green sight.
Although, if you remove it,
that effect is reversed.
So basically, if you don't need
really, really good red/green
discrimination, you
can take higher doses.
But in general, I
recommend no higher
than 10 milligrams
a day-- usually just
two or 5 milligrams.
One other benefit or
other use of tadalafil
is that it increases the
density of the androgen receptor
similarly to l-carnitine.
So that's an
interesting benefit.
Another benefit is
that if you give it
to people with
nocturia, which is
urinating at night
in general, it
will cut the episodes in half.
So it could go
from 2 to 1, which
can make a big difference
for your sleep, which
will secondarily make a big
difference for your growth
hormone and testosterone
optimization.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
So you said 2.5 to
5 milligrams per day
is typical for these
prostate enhancing effects.
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: And you
mentioned the potential side
effects on adjusting
visual perception.
As a vision scientist,
that rings in my mind.
But in terms of red/green
color discrimination,
I'm guessing unless
you're going to be
a subject in one of the
experiments in my lab
or you want to be
a fighter pilot,
chances are you can
probably get away
with a little less red/green
color discrimination.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
It's not considered
clinically significant
unless someone is
a commercial pilot.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Great.
KYLE GILLETT: So if someone's
getting their pilot exam,
that's one of the
things we look for.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So
commercial pilots aside,
you might want to ask
your doctor about low dose
tadalafil for sake of
enhancing prostate health.
Certainly monitoring PSA
prostate specific antigen
is important.
I can give an anecdote there.
When I tried sermorelin, one
of the surprising side effects
that was not welcome
was a dramatic spike
in my prostate specific
antigen. No one
could explain to me
why that would happen,
but when I stopped
taking sermorelin,
it went back to normal.
So that's one reason I
avoid sermorelin, at least,
frequent use of sermorelin.
PSA should be kept--
what-- below levels
of somewhere between 1 and
4 is considered healthy?
Is that right?
KYLE GILLETT: It
depends on the age.
If there's a 20-year-old,
likely between 0 and 1.
If there's a 40-year-old,
likely between 1 and 3.
And then if there's
an 80-year-old,
it would not be abnormal
to have a PSA of 5
and have that be well
within the reference range.
Another thing we should
mention about PSA
is if you do take a
5-alpha reductase inhibitor
like finasteride or
dutasteride, often
these will cut your PSA in half.
So if you-- for example,
if you have a PSA of 6
and you start finasteride
or dutasteride,
and then you recheck it in
six months and it's 6.5,
that is a huge concern, because
that's actually doubled.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I'm glad
you brought this up because I
almost overlooked
the fact that I
get a lot of questions about
drugs to offset hair loss.
Most of those drugs are going
to operate through the DHT
system-- the dihydrotestosterone
system-- for the reasons we
talked about before.
DHT receptors being on the
scalp and causing beard growth
on the face.
Is it the case that a number
of people taking things
like Propecia and other
things to block the DHT
or disrupt the DHT
pathway are going
to experience diminished sex
drive, diminished motivation
and general vigor?
And if, so are there
alternatives like topical DHT
antagonists that they
might use if they
want to keep their hair, but
not have those negative effects?
KYLE GILLETT: The way that
I think about hair loss
is you have your fertilizers,
also known as growth agonist,
and then you have
your anti-androgens.
Whether they're systemic
or topical, there is both,
but that's the general laymen's
way to think about hair loss.
If you're only putting
fertilizer in your hair
but you have androgenic alopecia
or male pattern baldness,
then those hairs will
still miniaturize,
and eventually, you'll
still have loss.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Such a
great word-- miniaturize.
It's enough to send anybody
off to find a therapeutic.
KYLE GILLETT: And
by the way, it's
difficult to tell
if miniaturization
is happening unless you
have a magnifying glass.
And you can use--
ANDREW HUBERMAN: I almost didn't
know-- for a second there,
I didn't know whether or
not you were making a joke.
You're talking about
miniaturization
of the hair follicle.
KYLE GILLETT: Correct.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: So what can
reverse that miniaturization?
Gosh, it's just a
fun word to say.
I'm going to just
keep saying it.
KYLE GILLETT: Each
individual has--
again, we mentioned
the androgen receptor.
Males only have one
androgen receptor gene
that's on their X chromosome.
So depending on how sensitive
that androgen receptor
is and depending on the density
of the receptors in the hair
follicle, you can have
an arbitrary threshold.
And you don't know
what this threshold
is until you start to
have miniaturization
and loss of hair.
But over the threshold,
the follicle will die
and eventually the
stem cell will leave.
But under the
threshold, you're OK.
Every androgen binds to
the same androgen receptor.
So there is nothing
special about DHT.
DHT is just a stronger androgen.
So the higher your SHBG--
things that increase SHBG
are beneficial for hair loss
prevention because you have
less binding of that receptor.
So if you think
about hair loss--
specifically, androgenic
or male pattern
baldness in the terms of
that androgen receptor
and everything in
general binding to it--
not just DHT, but also
testosterone-- it's helpful.
It's just that DHT
is a huge battering
ram whereas the other
androgens are just
light presses on the door.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Got it.
So are some of the
topical DHT receptor
antagonists going to be a
better choice for people
that want to maintain their
hair or grow more hair if they
want to avoid side effects?
KYLE GILLETT: Likely so.
Some individuals
benefit from systemic--
a systemic decrease in DHT
for a couple of reasons.
One could be prostate and
then one could actually
be hypertrophy of
the myocardium.
So DHT also disproportionately
thickens the ventricle.
So for someone on
TRT, that might
be a benefit that is
prone to thickening
of the ventricle at baseline.
However, many people that have
just a bit of predisposition,
they can use things that
are topical anti-androgens.
Ketoconazole is one
of them, caffeine
is actually another one.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Wait--
drinking caffeine?
KYLE GILLETT: Topical caffeine.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh,
I was going to say
my hair tends to
grow pretty fast,
so it might be-- but I
drink a lot of caffeine.
So topical caffeine?
Really, rubbing
coffee on their head--
KYLE GILLETT: Yes.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: --or
taking caffeine tablets--
and how does it-- wait, you
have to explain how this works?
How do people get caffeine
into the hair follicle.
KYLE GILLETT: Topically, the
caffeine enters the scalp
and crowds out--
somewhat crowds out the
androgen. It is a weak effect.
It's likely just strong enough
to be clinically significant.
Usually, caffeine is put into
formulations with other things
like ketoconazole that are
also weak anti-androgens.
Of note, spironolactone can
be prescribed topically,
but it is absorbed
systemically because the size
of the molecule.
So unless your
doctor specifically
prescribes that for you,
especially as a male,
do not use topical
spironolactone.
Topical finasteride is
also a smaller molecule,
so it is also
systemically absorbed,
but it is not extremely
well systemically absorbed.
If you take topical
finasteride, then usually
your systemic DHT will
decrease by about 30%.
Topical dutasteride is likely a
tiny bit systemically absorbed,
but it's unique
because it's half life
is much faster at a lower dose.
So topical dutasteride will
not affect your systemic DHT
at all, and I've seen this
anecdotally on many people
on topical dutasteride therapy.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: We're going
to have to get you back on here
to do an episode all about DHT,
and hair loss, and hair growth.
Again, not a topic that I
focus on a lot for myself,
but that I get a
lot of questions
about from men and women.
KYLE GILLETT: One thing
that we could mention--
I got a ton of questions about
turmeric and curcuminoids
after the last episode.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Oh,
yeah, I had reported
my own anecdotal experience that
taking turmeric really crushed
my DHT levels and I
did not feel good.
I mean, it crushed all sorts of
positive feelings of vitality.
The moment I stopped taking
turmeric, felt great again.
KYLE GILLETT: Many
people report this.
And the interesting
thing about turmeric
is most of it's beneficial
action-- not all of it--
some people benefit
from systemic turmeric.
And some people that
can tolerate it-- well,
it's actually great
for the prostate.
But most of the action, it does
not need to be bioavailable.
It acts on the gut microbiome.
So you can take turmeric,
and if it is not absorbed--
some turmeric is put in special
formulations like micellar,
or liposomal, or complexed.
But a lot of it is put
with black pepper fruit
extract, which is also known
as bioperine, which is actually
also a 5-alpha
reductase inhibitor
and it affects liver cytochrome.
And so many supplement companies
put this black pepper fruit
extract--
bioperine-- in
almost everything.
So some people are
on really high doses,
and that could
also be making most
of the effect of people who
do not tolerate turmeric well.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Yeah, I avoid
turmeric like the plague based
on that one previous
experience because it
was clearly turmeric that
caused the negative effect.
Coming off it, everything
reversed rapidly.
And the bioperine-- the
black pepper extract--
I also avoid that like the
plague based on everything
you just said.
I want my 5-alpha
reductase, I want my DHT
to be optimized simply
because my understanding is
DHT is the more
powerful androgen
and it's the one that-- yes,
it causes a little bit of hair
loss and I've got a few
patches here and there,
but I'm willing
to live with that
based on all the
other wonderful things
that DHT optimization does.
I'll quickly mention
a few other things.
One, saw palmetto is
also a 5-alpha reductase
inhibitor, but only a
couple of the isoenzymes.
There's three main isoenzymes,
and a lot of the problem
is that you're inhibiting
a couple of the isoenzymes,
but not the other one.
Finasteride inhibits 1 and 2.
Dutasteride actually
inhibits all three.
And finasteride
inhibits the isoenzyme
that is in genital skin, but not
in the skin throughout the rest
of your body.
So a lot of the side
effects of finasteride,
which is loss of sensation
and loss of erectile function,
have to do with
the disconcordance
between the sensitivity of
the genital skin and the skin.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Again, another reason
to not disrupt
5-alpha reductase.
And we'll definitely get you
back on here to talk about--
I think we should just do
a whole episode about DHT,
because so often when
people are thinking
about optimizing hormones,
especially males trying
to optimize their hormones,
they're thinking testosterone,
testosterone.
Maybe nowadays, they
think a little bit more
about free testosterone and
maybe they think about estrogen
as also being important--
not to crush estrogen.
But DHT is, at least to
my mind, the linchpin
of so many of the things that
subjectively people are really
focused on-- libido,
motivation, drive, et cetera.
I have one final question--
it's just a brief one,
but many of us have heard
that the BPAs that are present
in plastic bottles and even
in certain aluminum cans
and phthalates-- a
difficult word to pronounce,
but a fun one
nonetheless-- phthalates--
and work by Dr. Shanna Swan has
shown that phthalate exposure
to the fetus--
to pregnant mothers and
to fetuses very likely
is negatively impacting sperm
counts, testosterone levels,
and even changing genitalia
size for the worse in males
nowadays.
I saw a beautiful lecture that
Dr. Shanna Swan did on this
when I was in Copenhagen.
And it's very clear
that it's negatively
impacting the male fetus.
She was also on Joe
Rogan's podcast.
I hope to get her
on this podcast.
However, what she
couldn't answer
for me was whether or
not phthalates, and BPAs,
and these things
present in plastics,
and some people
claim in tap water,
are bad for males after
they're born and after puberty.
What are your thoughts on--
or I should just ask you,
do you drink water out
of plastic bottles?
Do you avoid drinking out of
cans that are not specifically
non-BPA containing cans?
And do you actively
avoid phthalates?
My understanding
is that phthalates
are most enriched in
pesticides, and that's
why you're seeing dramatic
drops in sperm and testosterone
levels mainly in rural areas
where they're dust cropping.
KYLE GILLETT: Yeah.
So I do avoid drinking out
of cans that-- or plastics
that may have BPA or
bisphenol A in them.
Bisphenol A is known
to bind to what
I would consider the
fifth estrogen receptor,
estrogen-related receptor gamma.
So it I would consider
it a xenoestrogen.
So phytoestrogens are estrogens
from plants, and in general,
they're not concerning or
clinically significant.
And xenoestrogens are
just other estrogens.
So I do avoid BPA and
I also test my water.
I use a water testing
service and I test it both
after it's through my water
filter and the tap water
that my two boys drink
almost every day.
And it's very interesting.
I only found one
microplastic just a bit
over the reference range, so
it wasn't a terrible tap score.
But even in developed countries,
these are widely variable.
As far as phthalates,
again, very
difficult and
interesting to pronounce,
but I remember
learning about these
because there is I
believe a lawsuit that
had to do with mac and cheese.
And this was probably
five years ago,
and I was coming up
with my list of--
each provider that
does obstetrics
has a list what to avoid
for the pregnant lady.
Sketchy deli meats
or high mercury fish
like swordfish and
salmon, and I actually
added processed mac and
cheese to that list.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Interesting.
Well, thank you for that.
I'm going to extract
your statement
that you avoid drinking out of
plastic bottles when possible.
I'm guessing you're not
neurotically attached to that.
If you were dying of thirst,
you might crack a plastic bottle
of water to survive.
But listen, Kyle--
Dr. Gillett-- thank you so much.
You gave us an enormous wealth
of knowledge, everything
from behaviors, to psychology,
to supplementation,
to prescription drugs.
We will make sure to
point out where people
can get a hold of you on
Instagram, and on Twitter,
and on other websites in
our show note captions.
But really, just on
behalf of the audience
and just for myself,
thank you so much.
You have an immense
amount of knowledge
and you're exquisitely good
at sharing it with people
in an actionable way.
So thank you.
KYLE GILLETT: My pleasure.
ANDREW HUBERMAN: Thank
you for joining me today
for my discussion with Dr. Kyle
Gillett all about male hormone
optimization.
And I just want to
remind everybody
that we will soon
have an episode
all about female
hormone optimization.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to
our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero-cost
way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on both Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify
and Apple, you
can leave us up to
a five star review.
If you have questions
for us or comments
about the podcast
or guests that you'd
like me to interview on
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
We do read all the comments.
In addition, please
check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you're not already following
Huberman Lab on social media,
we are Hubermanlab
on all platforms-- so
that's Instagram, Twitter,
LinkedIn, and Facebook.
And all of those places,
I describe science
and science-related
tools, some of which
overlap with the contents
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
but much of which is distinct
from content on the Huberman
Lab podcast.
So again, it's Hubermanlab on
all social media platforms.
During today's episode and
on many previous episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast,
we discussed supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people derive
tremendous benefit from them
for things like sleep, hormone
augmentation, and focus.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed
on various episodes of
the Huberman Lab podcast,
please go to
livemomentous.com/huberman.
We partnered with
Momentous because they
are extremely high quality,
they ship internationally,
and they formulated supplements
in the precise ways that
are discussed as optimal to
take for various outcomes
here on the Huberman
Lab podcast.
If you haven't already
subscribed to the Huberman Lab
podcast newsletter, it
is a monthly newsletter
that includes summaries
of podcast episodes
as well as toolkits, all of
which are completely zero cost.
All you have to do is provide
your email to sign up.
We do not share your
email with anybody.
You do this by going to
huberman.com, go to the menu,
and tab down to newsletter.
Provide your email.
You'll get a confirmation link.
Click on that link,
and you'll receive
our monthly newsletters.
And you can also access any
of the previous newsletters
that we've released, including
the toolkit for sleep,
for fitness, deliberate
cold exposure,
and so on by going
to huberman.com,
going to the menu,
going to newsletter,
and there, you'll see those as
immediately downloadable PDFs.
Thank you, once
again, for joining me
for today's discussion about
male hormone optimization
with Dr. Kyle Gillett.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]